Hey everybody,
this is a special late night episode of the Joe Rogan experience podcast,
and we only have one sponsor.
It's on it.
O.
N.
I.
T.
If you've heard this podcast before,
you've heard these fucking commercials for,
you don't need the skin.
All right?
You don't need this aggravation in your life,
right?
You don't need this shit.
So I'll leave it at that on it.
O N,
n.
O.
N.
N,
two just two n's,
O n.
N.
I t.
Use a codename Brogan.
Save 10% off any and all supplements.
It's not just supplements there,
it's a,
it's basically human performance website.
If you've never been there before,
go check it out.
Fitness equipment,
all kinds of cool supplements,
uh,
hemp protein powders and good shit.
Go check it out.
Alright,
that's it.
Boom.
Uh,
this weekend,
too bad.
Sold out.
Haha.
Tomorrow night,
the Ice House.
Um,
other dates go to desk squad.
Dot TV.
Uh,
Brian,
we'll have all,
uh,
of,
his future comedy shows up there as well as a friends of ours.
And,
uh,
my website,
Joe rogan.net.
There's a tour section and it's uh,
it's,
it's got all the stuff over there.
Uh,
we'll ask us hold out.
Sorry bitches.
You snoozed you lose.
Um,
and Winnipeg sold out too,
so I can't wait to go
counted again.
When are you going back to Texas?
I want to go to Texas.
So kind.
I know you do.
We should probably schedule a gig.
I know.
Once you get a night at the Houston Improv,
I would love to.
Yeah,
we're Addison.
Do Addison,
can you write it down?
I wouldn't do it.
I want to do a weekend or a week of like Houston,
Dallas,
Austin doing,
it'd be awesome.
You can do it.
Book it up.
Just make some calls.
All right.
Uh,
Kelly starts here and we're going to get cracking.
Cue The music,
the Joe Rogan experience.
Joe Rogan podcast my night.
What are you doing?
New Mix.
You are not a DJ.
You fuck now Kelly,
how are you sir?
I'm,
I'm good man.
Thanks very much for doing this,
man.
I really appreciate it.
Absolutely.
Forrest Griffin recommends you.
That's good enough for me.
And your book is
fascinating.
I started looking into your book and as I was telling you before the podcast,
I've been having some back issues myself.
I have like a bulging disc in my neck,
the name becoming a supple leopard.
What'd you come up with that name?
Couple of ideas.
One is,
uh,
have some tactical friends who are scary and uh,
they're always stiff and messed up.
And you know,
he told me Kelly,
the leopard doesn't stretch.
And I was like,
well that's good.
I'm glad you're using that leopard defense because a,
you're not a leopard too.
You don't know how to leopard feels.
But then I started thinking about like leopard can sort of attack and defendant
full physical capacity.
You don't see the leopard will activating it's glutes are warming up or
prepping.
It's just awesome.
So why the hell don't you have full physical capacity?
Why you're in pain.
You know,
the resting state of human beings should be paying free.
You're designed to be 110.
What's going on?
Why is that?
Why?
It's because you suck at moving and you're your human being.
You make a ton of movement errors.
No one ever gave you the software for your beautiful hardware,
you know,
you're beat up,
you'd have to take some injuries.
You eat like crap some times.
That's a big one isn't it?
The software for you,
beautiful hardware that goes with the mind as well.
Like Matt just managing a human,
it's
difficult.
It's not that easy.
Who says it should be like not an easy skill?
So the bottom line is that we've been sort of kind of sold this horrible mass
that like you can just get on the treadmill.
You don't have to think bullshit.
Like you are a very,
very skilled human being.
That skill takes work probably work every day.
So meaning that you can't just get on a treadmill and be a healthy person with
no pain.
Like you have to do physical,
real physical work.
You have to do real workouts.
Well,
I think we've moved beyond,
I think everyone knows you need to probably put the time in under some weights.
You probably need to breathe really hard.
But really talking about as being a skilled human,
can you do everything that a human being needs to be able to do?
Yes or no?
Can you,
can you squat down with your feet together?
Like you're in Thailand having dinner?
Yes or no.
If you can't,
you don't have flank or range of motion.
Why not?
That's why I have plantar fasciitis.
That's why you're totally Achilles.
This is why you have back pain.
So the thing is that you're,
you should be very,
very skilled and you're thinking very,
very skilled in your and cultivate the practice.
350 years ago,
Musashi writes the book of the five rings.
He says,
your combat stances,
every stance and you're like,
wow,
that's so deep with the short sword goes,
your belly needs to be firm.
He's talking about your core,
you know,
from your feet to your knees.
You need to be able to create tension,
which probably talking about torque and having your feet straight.
So we're not the first people to take a crack at it,
but we are the same people who've made the same mistakes over and over again.
And you should be skilled and we don't teach the skill.
You've been spending your genetics and then you wake up one day and you've
herniated disc and what the hell happened.
So your,
your skill in movement,
like you need to know how to stand,
you need to know the correct posture.
Is that what you're saying?
Like that kind of thing.
Or
look,
my life's work is dream as a child was not to lecture adult men about posture.
Like this is not that the apex,
but it turns out good standing position and yoga is called Tadasana,
right?
You should know how to do that.
Yes or no.
And it's also the setup position for the deadlift.
The problem is that it's hard to kind of understand what positions need to be
in,
what is full range of motion.
Finally,
we have a language and that language is the modern language of strength
conditioning.
If you can press and pull,
enroll,
you know,
we,
you hear the debunked,
uh,
thinking about the old strength coaches say like bench press.
It ties the shoulders to the arms and you're like,
what the hell does that mean?
Well,
it turns out if you teach kids to create torque off of a fixed object and
explain what the purpose of that is,
you need to be skilled.
Well then it turns out in guard you can create torque off of any position you
can grab,
grab the shopping cart and being a stable shoulder position.
So it turns out that the posture that we adopt day to day work right now,
are you in a good position or a bad position?
Horrible business once or twice in a horrible position,
24 hours a day.
Is it a,
is it okay to be unconscious in a Zombie and turn your abs off?
You've already scared him so much that he'll never work out for like the next
month is not going to work out.
Now you're freaking them out,
man.
Every time,
like I know I slouch my whole,
my whole life is slouching.
If I sit like this,
it looks like I'm trying to show off my delicious boobs.
But you should.
That's how you should think.
This is how you want to be healthy.
Just tell the world,
here's my delicious,
but I've been doing that lately,
man.
I'm telling you that is,
there's been a bunch of different things that I've done lately that a medicated
my back pain,
but one of them is,
I've been really,
really cognizant of my posture for like the first time in my life.
I have a horrible slump and I just didn't think it was no big deal.
I thought it was like,
so I don't like standing up straight.
What do I give a fuck?
But I didn't think it had like health repercussions,
but I didn't think the damage it can do for your
discs.
Well let's,
let's look at it.
So you know,
you,
you get away with it.
You're pretty good athlete.
He had been an athlete your whole life.
You know your black belt,
you know how to train,
you take care of yourself doing these things and all of a sudden something's not
working right and they type.
One error that we make is as humans is that,
hey,
I've always done it and I'm the could be the best in the world.
I know so many gold medalists and so many world champions.
We'll record holders who have terrible positions and bad mechanics and pain.
They're still the best in the world,
so you can't use that.
I'm the best in the world.
Excuse.
The issue is,
are you optimized?
Are you in the best position possible for you or we have maximize your
potential.
Comma,
we use pain as a lagging indicator and wait until I have pain,
swelling,
numbness and tingling,
loss of range of motion.
Then suddenly,
oh,
I have a problem that's like driving your car around until it blows up and
they'd be like,
I should put that one on.
Yeah,
I know.
I fucked up and not getting regular massages.
I know I fucked up by not doing enough yoga.
I know,
I know.
No,
no,
that,
that's not sincere.
This is the problem.
Is that right?
Yeah.
So massage is great and it helps you to downregulate take care of your tissues.
You know,
having some experience.
That idea,
right?
It's a great and stretching,
but the problem you stretch and we'll talk about that stretching,
it doesn't work.
Stop stretching after you work out.
Stop stretching.
But how do you get really flexible?
Well,
we,
we take a systems approach that doesn't include the word stretching because
stretching is sort of being co opted by.
Thinking about lengthen your muscles.
So let's take a look.
Let's take your neck for example.
Right?
One of the things we look at is,
you know,
is your spine in an optimal position?
Yes or no?
And what we see is that if you're rounded and your thoracic spine,
we'll get that little hunch,
right?
Right.
Which is easy.
If you're a texting are sitting all day long,
your head ends up a little forward for every inch in front of your center of
mass.
Your head is,
it's plus 10 pounds.
So your head was 11 pounds plus inch.
It's another 20 points.
Eight.
Okay.
So it's not a lot going on.
So let's extrapolate that out.
So running 400 meters,
that's 330 steps,
right?
That's 330 loads.
If you look at sort of the,
the flection load moment on your neck,
extrapolated out times forced in one line is that your nervous system is an
optimized this,
this is the physiology of the human being is no longer debatable.
We know what the best position is.
If I put your head in this position,
I can decrease your force production instantaneously.
When did everybody sort of come to a consensus on this?
Like when did people really start understanding like real physical training and
how do you correct bad posture and issues?
Uh,
like what you're talking about is,
this is like fairly recent.
I would say this is a very recent and the reason it's recent when the book came
out,
right?
When we start MobilityWOD the issue is that for the first wad workout of the
day,
is that what it is?
The idea is let's crossfit fuckers in their acronyms.
Hey,
we'll do thrusters later.
It's cool rosters.
Look,
the bottom line is
we kept the guy who's got a book about being a supple leopard that he wants to
do to thrusters.
What is this show?
Fill in the blank.
I'm from San.
You just say that to be,
I lived there.
I was a child.
So,
uh,
it's a great town.
Come fed thrusters.
Okay Buddy.
Settle down over there.
Sorry,
I don't even remember where we were.
We were talking about how long this information has been out there.
So look at,
look at what's happened with the onset of the Internet.
We have literally kind of hit some kind of threshold where for the first time in
real time we have the best practices test,
retest being shared platforms.
Coaches are talking to a strength,
coaches talking,
nutritionists.
Let's leave as your own,
uh,
you know,
show as a model.
Look at the people you've brought on,
right?
Experts in their fields,
legitimate.
And for the first time we start to kind of tie in these very disparate systems.
Uh,
you know,
suddenly nutrition guys were talking to a gymnast,
talking to physios and were able to connect the dots in ways that we wouldn't,
I mean,
2000 years ago,
the yogas figured out that putting your arms over your head didn't align.
The shock was it put the shoulder into a stable position.
You know?
And so it's not like we haven't taken a crack at the human condition before,
but for the first time we can sort of integrate the fields.
Well,
turns out that that that shoulder position is the same position.
You should have your shoulder if you're pressing or if you're a young gymnast
blocking,
it's the same shoulder.
The,
that motor control and technique has been worked out for us because humans are
obsessed with performance.
They're obsessed with lifting heavier weights and going faster when we start to
kind of underlie the physiology and a match that up with the principles.
Now like,
look,
if you go into any,
any gym on the planet,
people are front squatting and running and lifting,
lifting and swinging kettlebells.
I mean,
my mom brags about her deadlift PR,
right?
She has an artificial knee,
you know what I mean?
Like she has her sleeping with dogs,
has an artificial knee,
and she does dead lifts.
Who doesn't deadlift an artificial knee?
Why not?
So right.
And she's gluten free,
right?
So if gluten free,
that's right.
So if,
if
that was on one where you can't,
I want to definitely get to the,
to the gluten issue.
That's a very controversial issue.
But it's not controversial.
I mean,
amongst a lot of people,
maybe not to you,
but amongst a lot of people,
the issue is suddenly we can tie these fields together and because we have the
way to share the information and then we also are,
maybe you've noticed we're in the center of a human epoch of the southern
renaissance for sure.
Like look at the MMA movement.
People are like,
Hey,
I should probably learn how to fight and rule and like the self south
empowerment,
I'm not going to have a pension.
I'm gonna have a four o one k,
I'm going to manage it myself.
Oh,
I'm not,
I turns out I'm,
I'm responsible mountain healthcare.
Like the set of responsibilities definitely shifted back to us.
The nutrition information is sort of distilled down to shift it back to us.
Like you can start making better decisions about your life and realize that you
have to because no one else is gonna do for you.
Right.
And I think we're,
we're,
we're in a culture of people waking up and for the first time now people are
engaged in real strength and conditioning systems.
They are front squatting,
they're working hard mean I think in a Pawel.
And so like one of his first books,
he,
there was a,
he was a Brazilian fighter who did the 10 minutes,
like snatch tests with the Kettlebell and animals killed them.
And it took him like 10 minutes or something,
right.
He waves about it now.
Like I have like 14 year old kids who can do it in four minutes.
So the work capacity model is out.
So everyone's now is realizing,
hey,
I need to work better.
I need to work harder.
I mean that,
I mean everyone shows up super fit now,
right?
They really do.
I mean,
everyone's got pull ups and they're working hard and doing Tabata,
we've gotten really good job,
but we're not still telling people what the best position is.
We're not,
we're not kind of connecting the dots because we can get away with a right,
a lot of bad checks until we get injured.
And then you,
you're the reason I think the reason we're having good success with the book and
with,
uh,
with our,
our video stuff and is that I'm going to see you either because you're broken or
because you're losing in.
Both of those things are the same conversation.
And one of the,
I think the real problems is that this,
this information has been mired in the injury prevention,
you know,
do this and you won't get injured being like,
I'm not injured now.
I feel great and I'm the best in the world.
So why should I give a care now we can start to say,
hey,
by the way,
this conversation is about where you're dumping Torque.
We can't get into good guard position where you're bleeding force on the wall
where you're,
you know,
and then we start having that conversation and it turns out that the shoulders,
the shoulder,
so if you start to understand the principles of movement,
do you understand what we're trying to do in the gym?
Then you can start to translate that stuff instantaneously to whatever sport or
doing.
So it's more of like a physical intelligence,
sort of a,
an idea that you're,
you're trying to impart physical intelligence like moving correctly.
Well,
it's moving correctly.
So Ti think about position.
Position is a skill.
Can you do all the things,
like if I asked you to,
um,
keep your spine flat and reach over and grab a case of beer,
can you do that?
Yes or no.
Like I don't,
I don't need a bunch of tests on your lumbar spine to look into stability.
Do you know how to brace?
Can you get into a good position and maintain that stability or something
simple?
Like we used ankle range of motion before because the people are getting blown
up running poorly with these new shoes,
right?
The flatirons fuckers,
those new shoes or no good.
Now they're amazing,
but you don't have flank or range of motion.
Your feet are weak.
You run like a duck and you don't know how to run.
So how rude.
First of all,
he's very aggressive.
I mean the royal you.
So I understand what you're saying.
What's happening is that we can either confirm nor deny what's happening is
we've got to make silly say,
you know,
if positions a skill,
do you possess the motor control?
Do you have the skill,
the technique to be able to do this?
Yes or no.
And then also do you have the biomechanics?
And the problem is we've gotten pretty good at the motor control.
We're figuring that out,
but people's bio mechanics are wretched and the differences,
the reason we have wad at the end of our name MobilityWOD is it takes some
maintenance.
You should a know that you probably take 10 minutes a day to work through your
crap.
We'll just,
you need 10 minutes of preventative maintenance on the car every day.
You know,
you've got to put gas in your car.
Just the way your nutritionist sort of dialed in the course of day,
you develop a practice of 10 to 15 minutes to some basic maintenance.
And then that allows you to deal with the things that
are front.
Like,
Hey,
my next killing me,
my back's killing me.
I have its problems.
Or it's just to go hunting.
So we look at a koby tears,
his Achilles,
you know,
how much did that cost him?
What's that cost his team,
you know,
in revenue.
What about a rod or a lady Gaga tears or hip,
she has reflux.
She has,
she had to refund through
those guys.
Or guys,
you don't understand.
That was awkward to just roll out there and they'd $30 million hip,
$30 million is how much he had to refine.
That bitch is powerful.
Powerful lady Gaga,
$30 million.
If you're hurt your hip,
what's a,
what's the word that you hate?
You hurt your hip.
Not that mom.
How much is your back pain cost?
So I think the real,
the real question is,
you know,
causing these issues.
Well,
it's a human right to know how to move that should not,
they should not be a physical therapist.
And I'm,
let's be clear,
I'm,
I have a clinical doctorate in this thing.
I should not be standing between you and knowing how to move more effectively
and you,
and knowing how to fix it.
This is,
stuff is so simple.
It's a human right.
That's what we're trying to spread the love.
When you see some people that have like ridiculous natural intelligence with
their bodies,
and then that's what I'm calling this,
right?
When it says there's a natural intelligence,
and it's much like some people just way better at doing whatever singing.
Some people could just fucking sing and some people just know how to move their
body.
But other people,
man,
there's some dudes like you just can't teach him certain things.
Like I remember,
um,
when I was teaching taekwondo,
there was always kids that would just learn everything so quick.
And there was always some people that for whatever reason,
their body just didn't move right.
100% right?
And then when you see a guy like that,
how do you correct that?
Well,
the real issue is,
you know,
at what point do we start to develop skills and kids,
right?
How do we,
what's that athletic language?
It's not about recess,
you know,
think about your wired to move correctly as a human.
So my daughter age,
11 months squats like westside style like that,
she does,
right?
Because it turns out all the contra,
all the conduits are there,
but you still got to run the wires through the conduits.
And that's why we get kids who came out of fighting some kind of martial arts
early on.
Kids command gymnastics early on,
some kind of movement system,
dance,
they all move better,
right?
And that was because there are some basic primary shapes that we've taught kids.
And then all of a sudden you have this language unto unto which you can sort of
layer athleticism.
But suddenly there's some kids who figured it out early on and it shouldn't be
an happenstance,
like every kid should know how to jump and land.
So how about this ACL injury rates in kids under 12 up 400% why do you think we
should have cured that?
Is that because of more competition?
Is it just because of poor movement?
I think we don't teach kids how to move.
I think we expect that this is a natural thing.
Can sit injured themselves though in athletics.
I mean I've,
I've torn to acs and it wasn't because of bad movement.
Okay,
fair enough.
So let's take all the orthopedic injuries on the planet,
right?
It's cost to vitamin a couple of categories.
The first category is pathology.
Some wrong with you,
right?
You have kidney infection or Lyme disease,
There's something sketchy going on.
Um,
one of my wife's friend's had back pain,
constant back pain.
They'd seen her.
Everyone's treated for back pain.
It turns out she had spinal cancer,
right?
She had metastasized cancer.
Well,
there's a pathology there that happens once in a while.
And that's why you're like,
hey dude,
you're my training partners.
Something's wrong with you.
Go get checked out.
This is our physicians.
We came up with ology beautifully.
The second is catastrophe.
Sometimes I work with every branch of the government,
all the tier one assets.
They're going to be parachuting down when at night in the land on a stump and
break their ankle.
You're going to get swept and have someone,
some fat guy,
Roland tear ACL.
That's going to happen,
right?
Those are 2% category problems.
Hmm.
The 98% is totally preventable.
It's you working in bad positions until you spawned d until you tell your labor
them.
Right.
That's it.
Yeah.
And it's also fatigue,
fatigue to cause your body to buckle on.
Do you occasionally cause you to have poor form?
That's true.
So the issue is,
you know,
can you maintain a position under the duress of cardio respiratory demand,
right?
You,
I heard you say a couple times,
you're like crossfit,
you know,
like give me a fighter.
Right?
Because the,
the expression of being able to hold these shapes and fight and wrestle under
huge metabolic demand,
respiratory demand is what makes fighting really good.
And people have really done a good job of taking the conditioning off the table.
Now,
some of these athletes are so conditioned,
right?
But if you lose position because you're breathing hard because your metabolic
under metabolic demand or load,
right,
or you're stressed and what you'll see is you'll see incomplete training and the
whole point of the training is to exceed your capacities so that you can
maintain the robustness and fluency of your positions so that when it comes time
to dance or do what you need to do,
you could do those things and you don't end up giving position.
So you're saying that,
you know,
understanding human movement and understanding how to do anything correctly sort
of will lead to an improvement in athleticism across the board.
100% one to one.
So if you walk like a duck,
let's just stay this,
like if we,
if we take a,
a poor Tim Silvia,
do you know Tim Silvia has no,
Tim Sylvia is a former UFC heavyweight champion.
Great fighter.
Just a big,
big giant dude.
But he always had a like a pigeon toed thing going on.
Okay.
So I think that was a,
is that a genetic thing or is it just slow?
Genetic is in his mom walked like that and his dad locked like that.
Any pattern like that.
So in the NFL for example,
they won't,
they won't draft you dude,
you wear flip flops.
This culture of wearing flip flops,
what happens to your ankle?
If I take away your,
your capacity to flex your ankle,
you're going to want,
I'm not going to have to walk through the ankle.
So what do you do?
You walk around the ankle.
So this is the mechanism for Bunyan.
If that navicular bone starts to collapse and you see that foot collapse down,
then that's a tell.
It's called a Patho pneumonic.
Tell for ACL injury.
In fact in the NFL scouts look for that fall into vicular drop that navicular
drop and they,
they downgrade you because they think you're more likely tear ACL.
So how did,
what is it called again?
Navicular drop particular bone is flat on the ground.
Totally seems like you'd be more likely to tell you race.
These are kind of going in towards each other all the time.
No Kid,
every child is born with flat feet.
No kid actually has flat feet.
And what ends up happening,
it takes a couple of years.
Arts just develop.
We sit around too.
But the turns out that your ankle works best when it's straight up and down,
walking straight.
So when the problem is that when you walk with a foot out,
you can still create a ton of torque in this stability.
You can kick people really hard,
you can run really fast,
but as soon as that lead comes behind you than what's happened is that your hip
isn't an unstable position.
You've added a little twist into your knee,
your ankle is collapsed and you're starting to dump torque so that that back
foot,
if you're pushing off that back foot to kick someone or hit someone,
you've lost a little force there.
It's a little forced bleed,
a little forced dump.
So imagine that you walk around like that position with your feet turned out and
you take 10,000 steps a day cause you're an average person,
10,000 steps.
So just do the math on that.
70,000 steps a week,
quarter million steps a month,
three main steps,
and suddenly you've practiced this foot,
turned out position.
The jumping and landing with your feet turned out is not okay.
That's the mechanism for so many of the ACL injuries.
All the foot injuries.
And is it preventable?
Yeah.
Your first thing is your coach is like,
Hey,
stand with your feet straight.
If we test you right now,
had you jump up from,
uh,
like uh,
from the bottom position,
you know,
up onto your feet.
If your feet were out,
I can sweep you so easily.
If your feet are straight,
you have options.
You can cut left and cut,
right?
You can jump.
But if you turn your feet out,
you lose this position.
So I can also look at your hip function.
So if I turn your feet out and your knees come in,
right?
That's what happens.
You shut your hip musculature off so he just not,
and you have a weak hip.
Hip is functionally muted.
You've basically put yourself into mechanically bad position.
I lose hip function,
which means that those power,
so it's not a genetic predisposition.
It's a training.
Early on it was incorrect practice,
practice,
practice.
So I was at Disney with my friend and my,
my friend's families,
like this girl's walking like a duck.
I mean we've talked about it,
you know,
he's like,
oh my God,
what did we do?
You know,
do we see an orthopedic surgeon looking for deck?
That's what that is.
Just cutting a big wide path.
She doesn't want to close it off.
Conservative girls,
we'll close it off.
They'll do it with a pigeon style.
But when you're not thinking that through,
because women are generating more torque in that position,
they just let you know what's up.
Do you want to be loose or do you want to create torque?
I don't think they're thinking like that,
man,
I don't know.
You don't have to think about it.
That's problem.
That needs to think about that.
This kid is like,
so my friend is like,
hey,
you know,
what do we do?
I'm like,
well,
have you asked your daughter not to wealth wealthy can duck cause it turns out
you need training and coaching and this is why your training partners.
And he's like,
Hey,
I have a,
can you uh,
make your feet straight?
She's like,
sure that.
And the problem was fixed from that on while.
But so a guy like Tim Sylvia,
who's in his thirties,
do you think you could fix that?
Like if you got with Tim,
can is,
no.
Well,
here's the deal.
My wife has this great saying,
she's like,
make a better decision.
She looks at me and she's like,
that's a bad decision.
So it's not a hard time believing that the way that guys frame is like Tim was a
great fighter in spite of his genetics.
So,
so what you're saying is how do I optimize my genetics?
How do we take the best athletes in the world and make them better?
And this is the revolution we're in right now.
It's not just about injury prevention.
I know that if I put you into a better position where you can squat more,
jump higher,
cut harder,
punch harder,
kick harder,
chances are that sort of aggregates into better performance.
Right?
Well,
imagine if it's someone jumping down from a wall of a hundred pound pack and
Afghanistan.
Do you think that that's a good position or bad position?
Or if I have to sprawl or get up and change directions from my officers,
this is the same deal.
The problem is we don't sort of connect the dots.
Look,
uh,
Daniel Coyle,
what's wrote this great book called the talent code.
If you guys read that,
we'll turn turns out.
Skill is a complex biological phenomenon.
It's it.
So what ends up happening is that when you practice a skill and what we know,
it takes 10,000 hours,
a million reps,
right?
Child has to do something six to 10,000 times before it becomes functional,
The key to adult learning is repetition.
You've heard all of this before.
Well,
it turns out that when neurons that fire together wire together,
and what happens is those,
that Schwann cell that oligodendrocyte comes in and myelinates that pathway.
So practice doesn't make perfect practice,
makes permanent.
So who you are right now is who you're going to be under stress,
who you are right now.
So why when you start cultivating a better position all the time,
because it's free money,
right?
And it starts to show up.
The greatest thing about competition,
especially fighting,
he said,
we're going to find out who you are.
We're going to find out what your conditioning level is or to find out what your
skill is.
We're going to find out where you go mentally when it gets tough,
right?
That's the point of why we train and why we fight,
because it helps us self actualize and see the problems.
When we start turning on this all into performance and it's gotta be measurable,
we can mention that.
I was having a call today on the way in with one of my Tour de France cyclists.
Unbelievable.
Phenomenal athlete,
right?
His foot was a little stiff in the ankle and his knees to wobble and you know,
and you think,
oh,
that's not good.
Would you imagine if I was walking and my knees wobbled every single time where
I kicked you every single time and you wobble will turn out as ankle was stuck.
And I showed him how to free up his ankle and guess what?
His wattage went up and he won the Tour de Swiss.
So it's not an accident.
His ankle was stuck stiff.
Oh,
just stiff.
Just needed to be worked out.
Imagine if you,
um,
it's not,
you know,
and it's not just stretching,
right?
Think about your calves,
for example.
They take tons of abuse running.
It can be upwards of what,
five,
six times impulse,
body weight.
Think about kicking.
So if your achilles straight up and down and it's designed to pull,
strap it down.
What happens when that ankle collapses a little bit?
Now your Achilles is off axis,
right?
Pulls laterally.
This is the mechanism for the,
the Achilles rupture is I take this very powerful tissue loaded sideways.
Well,
not only is it am I likely to injure myself,
but that tissue doesn't work very well.
It gets stiff.
So if I just pull on it,
you know,
well let me just stretch.
Oh,
that didn't change anything because I'm just pulling on the kind of contractual
features.
We're not dealing with the stiffness of the,
the sliding surfaces,
the Fascia or it's a muscle stiff is the joint capsule.
You just have to start thinking this in a systems approach.
And the thing is,
it's stinking easy.
We use jump stretch bands and lacrosse balls.
This information should,
is this been like kind of kept in this dark closet,
you know,
oh I have knee pain,
I can,
I can rear naked choke 17 people and fight and do all these things,
but I don't do with my knee pain.
That's ridiculous.
You're an incomplete athlete and complete human.
So what do you do to people that are fucked up like that?
Like we're comes to and he's got knee pain.
You just correct the way he moves.
The first thing and the reason we all have to go after movement first is that
the movement often if we correct your movement patterning and then the gym is
not just about getting stronger,
fitter,
it's about perfect practice.
Like the formal language of movement,
like the gym is like the best expression of modern human ballet,
right?
It's the formal,
but we are freestyle dance battlers that's what we do.
But if you can speak to this performance going freestyle dance for hours.
Sorry,
you can't keep me down.
The issue is that one is how do I,
how do I make the invisible visible?
How do I take a guy like that?
I can see it.
I'm really good.
You can see it in pretty soon.
What's going to happen?
It's honestly,
if you pick up this book,
and I'm not trying to pitch this thing,
but you can see it,
you start to get the vision and it's so bad.
You can see how people are moving.
You go to the Olympics and all,
you just watched the Olympics and you're like,
that guy could go faster.
Why is his knee wobble and why is that sh that shoulder and complete?
So first thing we do is we prioritize the movement.
Can you correct the formal language of that?
So because especially in a pattern that's,
I've done a billion times,
like let's take my Olympic rowers,
right?
These Olympic rowers have pulled 30 or 40 strokes a minute for 200 kilometers a
week for as long as they've been rowing.
It's insane.
The patterns.
So how am I going to break that pattern?
Am I going to mess with them?
No,
that's your coach's job.
Your coach teaches you technique.
My job as a strength conditioning coach or as the training partner is to make,
give you a new pattern in this very formal language like called front squatting,
swinging kettle bells,
you know,
doing the basic language,
finding the problems,
addressing the problems,
practicing the movement.
And guess what?
Every single time our athletes can put it back into the field more effectively.
So what you're saying essentially the for the layman is when you're doing
something like rowing,
it's a very specific movement.
So you essentially provide movement in the opposite direction or like if you're
pulling,
pushing like here's what you're doing,
we've,
we've basically confused people because there's all of these movements,
right?
But mainly the spine has a few shapes.
It needs to be built to pick something up with my spine braced.
Right,
which is straight,
straight up and down,
up and down brace correctly.
You probably need to be able to do a somersault,
don't you think for role as a foreign language.
Right?
So that's a globe.
That's a globally flex position.
Can you do that?
Yes or no.
Right.
If we had to do that,
we would see that you had a little dead spot and your thoracic spine word stiff.
Right.
We're not getting good rolling.
Um,
if I was going to,
you know,
swim or,
or block a Bot net,
you know,
a ball at the net as a volleyball player,
we'd see the same thing.
You need to be in that globally.
Flex Ang globally extended positions.
Do you have fluid fluency?
Like Ido portal,
great thinker about this stuff.
He's like,
what do you mean you can't roll backwards and roll off your back?
Like that's how you fall a lot backwards.
So why haven't we taught people this basic tumbling skills?
Oh,
that's what gymnastics is.
So your spine only does a couple of very serious things,
you know,
and we can,
we can make some nuance changes,
but that's the basic language.
The shoulders have couple basic laws that when your shoulders are in front of
your body,
right from your,
from your hands up to your head,
they have a stable position.
And that position is external rotation.
It's trying to break the bar.
You know,
all these cues screw your feet into the ground as a cue to create torque.
Instability of the hip.
Well,
it turns out if you understand the movement principles,
then when you're in these shapes,
you're climbing or in a bad shape,
you can always create a stable position or a position where you're going to
generate the most force.
Practicing that in the gym and also making it easy to understand because when
you're fighting,
it's hard to see where you're giving away torque and power.
It's hard to see how your limited hip function,
right?
You're missing hip flection like bringing your knee to your chest.
You can't do it,
but how do we know?
Well that's the mechanism for hip impingement and torn labrum and all the
problems we see,
but if I asked you to squat,
can you get into the bottom position of a pistol,
for example,
right?
That that basic shape,
it's not an accident that you know the size in like the kneeling position,
like a lot of people can't kneel.
That's a full range of motion of your ankle.
You know that that these are the basic shapes,
the formal languages of movement,
fighting,
gymnastics,
all of these things.
People have worked this out,
yoga and so you don't need to do yoga.
If you lift heavy weights and you understand what you're doing.
If you're putting your arms over your head and snatching,
you probably are doing muscle snatch,
a swinging a Kettlebell.
Chances are you understand yoga without understanding,
Yo,
you don't need to do yoga.
I think people do yoga for other stuff too.
Right?
Well,
this is,
this is also,
we got to get into this head girls' butts.
Girls' butts,
but do,
do you think girls do it from girls butts?
They want to build their butt up.
It's weird how it never works though.
Isn't it strange?
This go never work.
We have to be a skinny fat,
skinny,
fat girl,
Skinny Faculty Yoga,
right?
Let me tell this story.
Oh,
please do.
I was in Australia with my family were staying at the Byron bad.
We've been there.
It's beautiful and there's a spa and my wife's like,
hey,
there's a yoga class.
You should take that fat guy.
Like it'll be good for you and it'll be entertaining for them.
So I show up,
there's like 20 girls already in their yoga costumes and the woman sees me and
she looks at me and just like,
look at you and you're like,
fuck this girl.
This guy.
He's huge.
He's going to be a flexible,
he's going to take up all my resources,
but I understand what the stable shoulder position is in any sport in any
platform because it's the same shoulder and we understand the physiology.
Can you get into that shape?
Yes or no?
Can you make your spine stable?
Right punching is the same thing is as being in downward dog.
Basically punching is,
well,
I mean you like,
you know,
just like,
do you understand what the stable shoulder position is before you unloads the
same thing,
right?
Do you,
are you organized or you know,
in a bad position,
many punches like especially uppercuts and hooks.
You're in a very weird position.
We're position,
but do,
can you express the full physiology?
So what,
there is a good position.
So the issue is if you're limited range of motion,
let's take forest,
right?
You know,
he's got a bad wing,
right?
He's missing some range of motion on that shoulder,
Some things he's been working on for a long time,
right?
He got dumped in a bad shape.
The question is,
you know,
he,
that limits his movement language down to very few.
Here's a few ranges.
He's very effective in some ranges where he's not very effective in,
sorry for us.
I'm giving away the keys to the castle here,
but uh,
it had to be forced Griffin at a bar fight.
But the real issue is that if you have one of the basic archetypes for the human
being is you should be able to put your arms straight up over your head,
rib cage,
down,
armpit forward,
right?
Like as if you're holding a dumbbell over your head,
Kettlebell gives you a little more breathing room.
But can you hold two 55 pound kettle bells over your head?
Yes or no?
That's full range of motion,
right?
But you need to be able to be stable here and stable here.
It's still overhead unstable here,
stable here,
still here.
So what happens is if I have full range of motion and I trained in these formal
ways of creating torque off these objects,
right?
I'm,
I'm swinging kettle bells,
I'm breaking the bar and bench pressing and pressing,
I'm doing pushups,
all the things we do,
then that gives me movement possibilities where I can still be in an tenuous
position and still generate force.
Right?
So I see what you're saying.
So in being able to press overhead is equally important to be able to press
sideways.
It's right because it helps me know what the stable shoulder position is and
that gives me options.
So is it really possible to generate the exact same amount of strength and
through the entire range of like kettlebells extended 90 degrees or no,
but we can still know what the stable position for the shoulder is.
So you strengthen it as much as you can.
Well,
there's always going to be gravity and leverage,
right?
So you know the front rack for example,
and listen like the good coaches like Dan John,
Greg coach says something like,
Hey,
she be able to pick something up off the ground.
He'd be able to carry it around and put it over your head.
Like that's pretty elemental.
Well,
picking up off the ground deadlift,
right?
That's a basic archetype.
Reaching into the crib,
grabbing my baby,
picking up the keg.
Someone's jumping on you and guard right there.
They wrap their legs around you while you're in standing position.
That's a deadlift,
yes or no.
So can you do that right?
Picking something up is the kind of this hang position that's just one of the
archetypes of the shoulder,
which is what Kamora when you're not,
I'm just a crappy fighter if I get it.
So do I have full range of motion of my shoulder and if I don't in this position
I'll compensate because I'm a human being and now my shoulders forward and now
I'm in a bad position.
So what ends up happening is that I start fighting and organizing and Jody
force,
like Chuck Liddell had that,
you know John Hackleman,
he called me up one time,
he's like,
oh my shoulder's killing me.
I'm like,
well he can't punch with this totally internally rotated crappy position forever
and not expect your shoulder desc right,
and how to fix it.
He started restoring is in range of motion,
cleaning up the movement mechanics in this other formal thing called training
and then that allowed him to suppress better mechanics.
When you start to see the breakdowns and it's,
it's part of it,
like how do you make the stimulus,
the adaptation for stem,
the stimulus for adaptation to get become a better human being.
To be a more effective athlete to train.
We put our kids under load,
like my daughter dead lifts dead lifts 20 pounds eight.
She's a monster.
My second daughter lifted
my uh,
we actually have a 200 pound stone that's awesome in the front yard and the boys
have to be able to pick that stone with a date.
My kids,
it's the first step.
Wow.
That's the first test.
Then there's an electrical writing to take her on a date.
They have to pick up a 200 pound rock cause seems fair to me.
Dude.
Can I try that?
Seems like she's going to have issues.
You can try it.
Men have tried and failed and tried and died.
Hell to say that.
All right.
So that's hilarious.
200 pound rock.
So I don't know if I could pick up a 200 pound rock or some shit has got to be
really hard to do.
No,
but does it shape like,
I think that's important.
Smooth round.
So wait,
how old is she?
She's eight.
But yeah,
they should wear a lie.
Why would you want to let your eight year old date somebody who the fuck is
going to be able to pick?
Yeah,
that's true.
That's messed up.
That's true.
Very good point.
Right?
So it's got a good one.
We have to,
we have to use a little external load to teach people shapes.
That's what you can do bootcamp and never learned how to move and some move like
crap and still get injured.
Look,
I mean the army has a million non combat related orthopedic injuries every year
and this is my shout out.
Tell him my kids in the military who listen to this podcast because there was a
ton of them who listened to you.
Right?
85% of marine force recon retiring full disability.
Why?
Because they have,
it's not just the IED is,
it's because we're putting kids in bad positions.
We don't train them for these basic shapes.
Basically iterations of how to protect the body and we don't do that.
Do the maintenance.
You can't be a marine.
Carry a hundred pound pack in a bad position,
be to hydrate.
Your body is going to get stiff.
So what do you do about that?
Well,
we know how to fix it.
You know how to reoptimize reclaim the positions.
So you're saying that guys that don't even get wounded in combat wind up being
debilitated just because of injuries.
So we were just because they move poorly fallowed or they just move.
They were,
they do fast.
So who taught you to run me?
Yeah.
I don't remember.
It's probably a long time ago.
Right?
That's the problem.
You just figured it out and we were like,
good.
You can run and you either faster,
you're slow,
you know?
Do you believe in running on the toes or do you think you should run?
He'll first plus let's,
I know there's this,
I'm so at debate about the side.
So the debate is I'm so happy you're happy if you take your shoes off and run
around here naked.
Right?
So it happens in the show.
Every now and then you got to run around naked.
No one will heel strike.
It's true.
Why is that?
Because it hurts.
Oh,
weird.
So you mess up the laws of biomechanics and you get this feedback that you're in
a bad position,
right?
So you stopped heel striking.
So every single person,
now let's just take the animal of the human as like an evolutionary machine.
You've evolving for two and a half million years over the last 10,000 years,
you really haven't changed the same.
Your little fatter.
My femurs little longer.
It's the same,
the same body 10,000 years ago.
Do you think,
and,
and keeping in mind that you're designed for adaptation,
right?
You can suck up bad diets and for decades and then it blows up in your face.
Right?
Right.
Can you can,
I know world champions who like eat little chocolate donuts and smoke and
they're still real champions,
especially Thai guys,
right?
Especially these freaky Thai guys.
Let's be out too late to get it.
They go get hammered and smoke cigarettes and kick your ass and they can because
they're look at,
look at their little bodies like little knives and bamboo sticks,
right?
Yeah.
I lived in Thailand for a month as a kid and was terrified.
Every little skinny with taiga.
I know it's
a very interesting style of finding any developed.
If you look at the,
the actual martial arts like in,
in a,
uh,
like an isolated form more ties,
one of the best ever.
It's like,
you mean they're,
they're grappling is not as good as a,
as a grappler,
but the real Moy Thai guys are awesome at NECC.
Mill manipulation as well.
Like with a lot of people don't realize is there's a lot of wrestling involved
in that.
So look at that.
I go after your nervous system,
right?
I shaved her head back and guess what?
I own the head on the body,
right?
Yeah.
The bull goes where the head goes.
That's not an accident.
So like Anderson Silva is the master.
He pins that shit down and people don't even realize it.
He's,
he,
I was like really strong guys with that.
I wrestled a in high school as a terrible wrestler and uh,
I had a coach or wrestled it like Iowa and he would get my head against his
head.
And then I was like,
okay,
take my lunch money,
hit my girlfriend like I was over.
Yeah.
And guy like Silva figures that out.
It's part of his fighting strategy.
Maybe he's conscious of it.
Maybe he's not.
Maybe he has a zen master is like control the head,
control the world,
you know?
But he's awesome at everything.
But he's also awesome at that.
He is awesome at everything.
And Lot of that is,
he's that genetic guy who figured it out early.
As a kid,
what we need to do then is to be able to go back and say,
what are the conditions that made him,
how do we teach kids not to work harder,
right?
But how to teach kids the skills of being human.
If you want to mandate and get rid of diabetes and obesity mandate an hour of
walking in schools a day.
But PE isn't about dodge ball.
Well it should be,
but it really shouldn't be about teaching the skills of jumping and landing and
lifting things up and physical education.
P T here's the language here.
Here are the skills like you can,
you have to read and write to able to get a second grade.
You should also be able to demonstrate and keep your back flat when you pick up
your backpack.
Yes,
really.
It's fine.
It's the one thing you're allowed to fail.
Right?
That's cool.
You're totally love it.
It's cool.
You don't know.
You know what announced verbus.
You don't have to put them together.
It's cool.
You don't have to read.
It's like,
it is kind of amazing that no one really cares.
If you ever get good at any sport,
you can get right through school without any,
any proper use of your body at all.
So you know that,
that's fine.
That crazy PE teacher guy who made your climb the rope and right.
You just have to show up.
You have to show up and you just dress right and then you pass them.
So the humans designed for adaptation.
You're designed for survival.
You can take the scratch and,
and keep going.
Right.
And you know this because you've ever been in a fight.
Yes.
Did you feel anything in the fight right away?
No.
It's the dirty secret about fighting.
You feel things afterwards,
right?
You know,
I mean,
why would Forrest Griffin keep fighting with people using his face as a punching
bag?
Right?
This is my question to him all the time.
He's like,
well,
I don't feel it.
Right?
He's an animal too.
But how about Jon Jones?
That's the perfect example.
After his last fight,
his toe had been completely torn and like roads,
right?
It's sideways.
And he didn't even realize it until he was,
he was talking and he looked down and saw it and then he blacked out and he sat
down and he kept going.
The interview going,
it was amazing.
So here's the deal,
you're you pain.
The pain pathway in the brain is the same pathways.
I'm moving pathway.
So when you're moving,
you do not get the pain
signal.
You just don't hear it because you're in constant motion,
your motion,
and you eat when your brain's not hearing the pain signal.
So by the time pain is punctured into your consciousness during movement,
we have a serious problem in the brain is like,
well bro,
and this is why everyone who knows who's ever exercised,
you lay down at night and then you can start to relax and downregulate and chill
and all of a sudden like your knee starts throbbing.
What's wrong with this bed?
I just twist,
my knee was brushing my teeth.
What's happened is you're not moving.
If you've been waking up in the middle of night cause your,
your back is killing you,
your neck is killing you.
What's happened is you've stopped moving,
you've stopped flooding the brain with that movement signaling and all of a
sudden you're just getting the paints and when you're getting the raw on
attenuated signal in the back of the system.
So that's one of the problems.
The second problem is that you maniacs have spent your lives practicing being in
pain.
So maybe the really the best athletes can just suffer worse when we know like
those athletes who can suffer,
like they just,
they can work harder than everyone else.
They can generate more watch.
And everyone else,
they can just it through fights have broken hands.
Well,
and then that's the third piece that once the adrenaline is going,
you are not going to feel it.
So we can't use that pain is a signal that you're in a bad position because
you'll always override that every single time.
I mean,
what's,
who's the,
the Gracie grandfather's like I just watched him tear my arm apart,
you know,
and I was like,
well big deal.
You couldn't feel it.
You know?
I'm sure you watched it.
You know,
you feel a lot of shit man,
like left hooks to the liver.
You always feel those,
those fucking hurt.
So they shut you down.
So it's so bad pain,
right?
That you can take a shot to the face.
But it's interesting that people go for the liver shot.
Why?
Because it punctures through that little,
that little wall,
right?
Yeah.
And when do people feel paying the first round or they start feeling pain in the
sixth or seventh round or were there,
where were the fifth round or when they're starting to really break down,
starting to get fatigued.
There's time for that stuff to send it.
So leg kicks as well.
That's another thing.
You fucking feel those man.
You feel though truthful little Shin to the gap.
Do you feel those dude,
those you feel it didn't matter if you're moving or not.
You know,
Glenn,
uh,
is the Glen Kudos is here.
He's,
he's the CO writers the guy felt for Glen Glen.
He's the guy who helped me a corral the brain and took all these photos in.
Glen has this thing where he walks around the house with his pants pulled up
really high and it's awkward at first until you understand that he's,
he feels like he gets stressed out if he can't just kick you in the head
spontaneously feels like the jeans are limiting them.
He gets a little stressed out.
Right.
Ricky?
He see he's actually wearing stretchy jeans.
He used to wear those chuck Norris jeans that had the gusset built into the
crotch.
I wore those bitches while he ate.
So you could move.
Right.
How many jeans,
how many pairs?
Have you ever blown out a pair of pants moving,
squatting down?
Definitely,
yeah,
on stage.
I've done it before the whole times.
Awkward.
Is that awkward?
Right.
These are designer jeans is that they're so designer that I can't move
functionally,
I can't move correctly.
It's like wearing an exoskeleton and uh,
so he,
so you start moving poorly or you know,
you don't hear the signals are designed for adaptation.
So the issue is that you can like kids with damage,
motor control systems have a diagnosis of cerebral palsy or that's what it means
if you have CP as a did part of your brain doesn't work the motor control part
yet those kids walk around find their cognitively totally intact.
They're totally bright geniuses,
but he just had this one part of the brain doesn't work,
but those kids figured out they turn the foot out,
collapse the ankle becomes stable.
They let the knee come in like a valgus knee,
like a torn ACL knee become stable internally,
rotate the hip poom become stable over,
extend the back,
become stable in of what the shoulder.
These are the kind of the body's secondary positions and stability,
that weird posture that they'd developed.
Position of mechanical stability and what we do because they don't have full
control of their bodies.
So the Justin,
that's the position that the fault to this stable position,
which is exactly the position you default to.
Can you teach someone who has cerebral palsy how to be stable?
Well,
they're already stable.
They'll read.
The question is that we know they're going to wear out their knee.
You're going to wear out their hip.
It's the same set of problems we see with people who jump and land wrong at
speed.
The same people,
when you see a bad front squat for gone wrong,
right?
And the knee comes in the back,
you know,
over extends the hitmen pinches.
This is the extra CCO,
the exercise.
The training is the basically the exaggerated reality of what sport is and or
movement in life.
You know.
So if you're,
you're holding your baby and your shoulders forward,
this is a fuel stable.
This is the position that a lot of my tac glass fleets have to spend time in
their weapons in this position,
shoulders forward.
So it turns out if I'm missing my internal rotation on my shoulder because I'm
designed for survival,
my has got a backup plan for me.
Boom,
shoulder comes forward,
I can still fight.
It can still move.
But this is why my shoulder starts to ache.
It's,
we're not working with my pack doesn't even work like a peck anymore.
Right.
The stabilizing my chest,
I'm living off this front delt.
That's how I tore my biceps tendon.
So what ends up happening is that I get away with it for awhile until I can't,
or until I have catastrophic injury or I start to get stiff in that position.
Then when I go put my arm over my head or do something bad,
you know,
I get,
I get hammered on it.
That's interesting because uh,
you know,
in a lot of positions,
the correct defensive position puts you in a very awkward place.
Like the way your body's rotating the color correct.
Defensive position.
Especially,
you know,
for kickboxing,
I'm like,
you're all hunched in and your,
your shoulders are pressed to your chin.
That's okay.
I can still be stable here.
So let's look at this position right arm forward.
That's not bad.
No,
no.
Okay.
So look at my shoulders.
I can still create a stable,
stable was trying to get at is that there's some techniques,
especially martial arts techniques where they require these crazy movements
would like we'll kicks things along those those acts kicks.
So,
but the,
the issue is,
you know,
is that done under high load or is it done at high speed?
So like punching for example,
and jumped me if I'm wrong,
right?
I typically start in a,
in a very stable shoulder position.
Heads and hands are up protecting the face,
right?
And I can punch as hard as I can.
The shoulder is mechanically very stable here.
Why can transmit a lot of shoulder energy from my shoulders,
from my hips.
But then the sh the arm unwind right for this moment.
And what happens is that our wines,
I create a little capsular slack,
which allows me to create high impulse speed,
but lot not a lot of force.
So in,
in being smooth with the movement,
you develop more power because it's faster and torques in and you've got a lot
of extra season.
This isn't a very stable position at the end for my shoulder,
but I don't have to be in a very stable position.
If I grab you then in this position what happens is it's a very different thing
then he turned right.
So why is it that you're grabbing a g or shirt?
You come into this position?
Well it turns out this is a stable position for the shoulder,
right?
That grip incredibly stable and dude judo,
You got that hand in there that gets you here.
And this is this flesh and instrumentation,
which is saying for folks who are listening to this on Itunes,
Kelly's just basically showing um,
like your,
your hand in your fist,
like sort of sideways in front of you and that that's a very stable position.
You were holding a bag of cat litter.
This would be the position and what you're doing sometimes little hold and
you're holding it up to your mouth.
The cat litter bag of death.
I don't know why you would be doing that,
but you know,
if you were doing it the same position or if you're holding your baby right.
I don't want my baby like this.
That'd be fucked up front,
right?
The front rack,
maybe position.
I can't be like,
put me down on your freak.
That's the Saturday lab.
We spikes the baby.
Don't do that.
Um,
I want to ask you this before I forget,
because I think it's really important.
When we were talking about with people with Awkward Movement,
what do you do for someone?
Like say they didn't do any athletics as a kid and then the 30 years old and
they want to try Jujitsu and they really don't know how to move.
Right?
So there's a local MMA school in our,
in our neighborhood,
and one of my friends is a Samba fighter and teaches it.
And these kids come in and they're like,
I'm going to be awesome,
you know?
And he's like,
oh Lord,
you can't even absorb force in this position.
So he ends up teaching the fundamentals of movement,
which look a lot like,
can you squat?
Yes or no,
right.
Ask Kids again in a good position in wrestling and guard,
you know like what is this,
this position like they're great.
You know.
So we have to do is give people the context and the language,
the language cues to be able to express that in that,
that form of fighting.
So fighting is the sort of the,
the high,
so for example,
I can say things like,
you know,
your shoulder isn't normal unless you can jerk.
So if those of you don't know what jerking it's in Olympic,
everyone knows jerky.
But in the Olympics when you're putting your arm over your head,
you stop cause your triceps get,
we can drop down underneath the bar.
So if you were picking up something really heavy,
like a log,
you know,
you'd jump it up and then drop underneath it and stand back up.
So that's,
that's the jerk neon with Lyft.
But what I'm teaching you to do is to be able to create a stable shoulder and
length in from both sides at the same time.
This same thing you would do is see if you are pushing someone and then had to
create distance away from them.
So I'm grab you.
I push like in like,
you know,
in football and I have to create distance,
you have to be able to kind of express this complex movement.
And the problem is we jump people into sport and hope they do it without having
any of the tools to be able to functionally may,
they might even have the range of motion to do that and they definitely don't
have the motor control to express that in kids who figured that out because
they,
you know,
if you ever did a,
uh,
like a backbend Ryan's kid,
that turns out to be a globally arch position,
right?
That's where your spine should be able to do.
And it turns out you're teaching kids what the stable front rack position is,
which is the position where they would limpic lift or create shoulder position
or this protected head position.
Right?
Or I'm grabbing you is the same expression as climbing rope or,
or,
you know,
doing that back man back roll.
So it's just all about stability.
And in these positions,
do you have the fluency,
the language of the human movement?
And the key is that you're seeing your shoulders,
this very complex system.
You're like,
it has a rotator cuff under a labor them,
and I don't even know what that is,
but it has one.
Right,
right.
But your brain is wired for movement.
It's not wired for musculature.
It's not wired for it.
You can't test a manual muscle test.
Your brain is wired to move.
So it's less this,
this phone.
Right.
Do you need to understand the technology behind that,
the crystal and how temperature affects battery life and how the interface of
the software effects?
No,
I do it from high.
Okay,
that's true.
I do it honestly.
I want to know what the fuck's going on in there.
I'm like,
this is crazy.
Who figured this shit out?
I can take your phone apart and take it apart by 4:00 PM I get you to tell.
So the issue is you need to be a master using the phone,
right?
Right.
You gotta turn on off.
You need to move your apps around.
That's all you need to know.
Your body is so complex that you don't need to know the engineering.
It's nice someone he's know the engineering you need to know the operation and
the operation is brutally simple.
Well it's really fascinating the idea of physical intelligence and it's
fascinating that it was always called physical education.
I think what you're saying makes a whole lot of sense and even more so than
teaching kids sports,
like teaching kids to use their body first is probably the most important thing.
Before they even engage in sports,
the Russians and the Chinese figured this out,
didn't they?
Cause motherboard,
modest fucker.
I think that a lot of shit,
man,
kids need to help bells that shit up,
right?
So they did figure it out.
They figured out how this front rack position isn't stable position,
right.
Putting your arm overhead and the snatch sales position.
Of course they figured it out because we're human beings and we're obsessed with
figuring out Olympic of [inaudible] has been around for a hundred years.
Maybe write a little more.
Do you think how many people blow out their shoulder?
We're learning the technique and then all of a sudden we figured out what the
best technique is.
And now we live in an age where you can go on the Internet and figure out how to
Olympic lift from the best Olympic lifters.
People are showing that APP on your phone.
So people show up now at that little MMA studio and they know a lot about in
May.
Right.
And they're fit and they like,
and that's because we're starting to see best practices come apart.
People are,
are,
are kind of coming together in,
in systems approach,
right.
The nutrition is dialed,
you know,
you talk to the average person who takes care of their body and they're like,
yeah,
I'm gluten free and I drink,
I put MCT oil and my coffee.
What about it?
You know what I mean?
Like that's,
that's my dog.
That's right.
Cause it tastes better.
It does.
So,
but you're right.
I think the,
the question then is where do we,
yeah,
can you take a guy yesterday was,
if you're teaching them sport,
like say if you're teaching them a marshal or something like that should almost
be required to teach them how to move first.
Well,
we,
it would be nice at some point though.
Don't you do some conditioning every single time you're fighting at the end of
wrestling practice or fighting practice,
Jujitsu,
you go over drills.
Then when you're done with drills to drill,
go to war are drills.
They're just going over the technique.
The technique and the technique has been worked out about what the position,
the fishing position is.
I'm saying there's no lifting weights or anything.
There is,
it's your body.
Right?
How much if stuff from,
I'm let's just say,
um,
one of my NFL coaches that I know,
he's a strength coach,
right?
He's like,
how much pressing to my guys need to do in the season?
All they do is out there and press,
right?
So we take young gymnast,
uh,
one of our kids that our gym,
it was a formal national champion just gymnast at Ucla,
right?
She is a machine and she understands innately what some of these really good
positions are because she's been doing it my whole life.
So now I take that skillset,
throw it into a sport and she's a monster.
So the question is what's the best way to create the,
these athletes with this ready state where then they can start picking up
sports?
Can I remodel people?
You betcha.
I've done it a thousand times.
We take people who are the best and we make them better.
We take people who are not the best and we break them into world record holders.
We take people who are injured in messed up and we said,
you know,
world championships,
the testing ground for this information is at the highest level of sport and
performance.
That's how we test it.
Then we take those principles and drills and we build has to be able to scale
from the injured athlete to the Olympian,
from the mom and dad to the kid,
to the fighter.
It's all the same.
So what you're essentially saying is that people who are not fit and not not
well rounded and then their athleticism are successful if they're fighters,
especially in spite of their ability,
their physical ability,
physical ability and balancing would,
they would take them to the next level.
That's right.
So we look,
we look at someone,
you know,
why,
why is that foot flat?
Well,
it's because they,
no one ever made an Olympic lift or practice jumping around in or,
or,
or consciously said,
when you jump up from the bottom position,
you know,
out of car and jump up,
I want you to hit and screw your feet into the ground.
So the key is how did I develop these skills and I can do it in my laboratory,
which is the gym because the gym isn't just about working harder,
right?
And you're working out,
it's not about working out.
It's about reintroducing these skills.
So let's take my,
some of my tactical guys,
right?
The Ninjas I get to work with,
they go in and clear a room.
They're taught to have feet straight because they need to sweep from side to
side and they need to have movement options,
right?
Just Watch,
oh dark 30 it's legit or active.
Valid.
Just guys walk in,
feeder straight.
They can clear the room side to side,
that can move.
So if I come in and one of my foot's turned out,
well I can't turn,
my sweep is off,
right?
My where my suite,
my weapon.
If you jump and land and you sweep from where her legs on my legs is turned out,
I can't move as efficiently in that.
So how do I develop that practice?
Because even when I'm cleaning a room with terrorists or in the middle of a
fight,
the last time I'm thinking about or should be thinking about as my foot
position,
that happens automatically.
That's why we do so many drill.
But in kickboxing and Muay Thai,
there's a lot of times when you're a real awkward positions and that's where
he's supposed to be.
No time.
Like,
how about kickbox and when you have to stand sideways,
like there's a lot of times when you throw in front light techniques,
yes you're standing very awkward.
So don't confuse the formal link,
which because my body can twist and contort.
You know,
if we teach rotation for example,
right.
We don't spend a lot of time teaching rotation cause it happens.
We spent a lot of time training the resisting of rotation.
Yeah.
When it comes time,
if the athlete is mobile,
right,
they can twist and resist that twist.
So you end up in these bad positions.
And my goal is to create a movement library with as much capacity in that as I
can.
So my,
my athletes are positionally strong.
They can be strong and stable and Jerry a lot of force in those bad positions
cause you're gonna be in bad positions.
So how about this,
so let's,
let's say in good positions if you can,
but if you're in bad positions because you do so many good positions,
you'll have more.
That's right.
And you'll be in a more optimized position,
awkward movements,
old wheel kicks and front leg side kicks where your body's completely twisted,
you're still going to have much more stability and you still won't compromise.
Cause we're still assuming that you can do everything that a human should be
able to do.
So full range of motion meaning but,
but that's nebulous.
So cause people were like what is full range of motion?
I Dunno,
a nebulous is a nefarious no,
uh,
you know,
unclear nebulous as I thought it was like something to do with space,
like the ceiling.
So if,
if the,
uh,
so the,
the idea is Google it and that's
where it feels like cauliflower,
like a brain warts,
bro.
Um,
in the form,
in the form of a clouder haze.
Unclear,
vague or ill defined.
That'd be lists.
There we go.
Like a Nebula.
Yeah,
like the girl of space.
So,
um,
you know,
I don't even know where we're going now.
Well we're just talking about athletes.
We're talking about teaching people movements.
So if you,
if you can,
if you can create a library of human library of positions and mechanics,
then what ends up,
you teach this formal language that athletes have the capacity they can be in
these shapes.
What I was going to say is,
you know the physiology is known to us.
So if you're missing range of motion in your shoulder,
because most of us are,
why?
Because you live in this,
does this environment,
you're designed to be able to create torque and you on your little laptop all
day long and he's bad positions and so you end up getting stiff.
Your body adapts to will exactly what you threw at it.
So if your nutrition is crap,
it's going to look like that and reflect that.
Right?
The,
the animal reflects the reality.
I had this great a PT instructor,
pediatrics instructors like muscles and tissues are like obedient dogs.
You just have to have the will.
So when I'm saying postures all about,
well,
posture is
about,
are you in a good position from the fucking wheel,
the stoma techs all the time,
right?
This is what Brian,
you've now coined this.
This is looking at my delicious breasts and now that's perfect.
It's sex.
I'm in so much pain right now.
Another good way to describe it.
So look what you've done.
Sitting for example,
is one of the most,
you're teaches someone who will never learn.
He's not going to listen to you.
What my,
I think my thing,
my injury is,
honestly,
it happens once or twice a year.
I crashed at somebody's house sleeping and weird and they have too many pills.
Like it's usually like older black men and and but like,
no,
and I'll wake up because I,
I've been drunk so much that like my neck is like this.
I've been sleeping all night that's actually come,
that can be called Saturday night palsy.
People fall asleep on their arm.
Oh,
kill the nerve.
And they actually ended up like long thoracic nerve damage,
I think I got you.
Yeah.
You just,
you sleep through the,
you know,
he wake up with pins and needles.
Yeah,
freaking out.
But if you pass out in a bad position,
that's why we put people in the recovery position.
Not only for the vomit,
so they don't numb their hands.
So what I'm saying is we will get back to the shoulder and second you've adopted
a sitting position right there.
That's wise.
It's basically laying down.
I'm trying to lay down as much as possible.
There's three,
there's three positions that still help you stabilize your back and standing.
One is that your butt squeeze,
such a position of your pelvis will move relative.
Right,
right.
And you can hear this cute,
excuse me about overhead,
right?
Point your toes in the air.
The gymnast,
we'll say if your butt's not squeeze,
you're not a good position.
You can tell a love gymnast.
Most of them are.
Most of them are 12 that's the ones,
the ones that are older than that.
Dude,
you don't have to go there.
So,
but so but such,
I assume you're not taking advice from 12 year olds on how to move.
I just assumed it was a 30 year old.
At least.
At least 18 I'm thinking of dirty over 30 that's what I'm thinking.
Hey,
hey,
I'm not the one who spent all the time about Thailand.
So,
so the,
so if your butt's such a position of your pelvis,
right and you squeeze your butt,
can you squeeze you about right now?
That's octomom through it.
You're not going to,
you're not going to last but more like 10 seconds there.
Right?
So it's impossible.
The second stability system is your abs.
And I'm talking about your trunk,
you know,
it's the whole,
the whole core,
right?
The whole system,
the sleeve,
all of that integrates to create high intra abdominal pressure and stability,
including your pelvic floor,
right sphincter to belly button.
Well,
the reason you key and shout is to create intra abdominal pressure so you can
stabilize the system.
Maybe you not me.
You sound like you use magic bro.
When I'm key,
I imagine you throw fireballs in my mind.
So the third thing is that we create,
we screw the feet into the ground,
right?
This torsion of kind of creating grip through the,
through the like the same grip.
Do you go towards no,
I externally rotate,
right?
So wax on,
wax off was teaching what?
Steven Seagal,
which throws in the same position screwing a light bulb in the way he runs on
look it runs.
Ever seen him run.
That's a perfect example.
Pull up Steven Seagal running.
Let's see.
It's a perfect example of see if Kelly can,
the way Steven Seagal runs,
and this is no disrespect to the young,
was an excellent martial artist and he's very good at Ikea.
I mean,
he was one of the first Japanese Americans rather to teach in Japan.
That's right.
I had a legitimate respected Dojo,
so no Kido is has they figured out to throw people.
You're winding the shoulder up into what position this extra about today and
then you have to tremendous amount of power with that.
This with wells,
with Judas,
same position that's rolled.
Getting getting yourself in a position,
looking at running.
Tell,
tell me what's wrong here.
Everything is wrong.
He has a lot wrong there.
Ge taught him how to run the Lewis.
He's got that.
Look at this.
Look how he's running.
Actually,
you know it's not bad.
He's running on the ball of his foot.
I've seen worse back.
He now he's getting older and he's getting over extended.
Oh,
you've got,
this is different.
This is all this.
This is a,
this is the guy who started get Stephan and fly around and play a little too
much music.
Everybody talks shit about him,
but the dude,
he's a bad ass,
legitimate martial artists.
He knows a lot about Marshall.
I wanted to be a navy seal.
Cook a legitimately takes advice from that guy.
Everybody thinks it's bullshit and I think I'm just trolling Lubick Liotta
Machita respects that guy enough to take instruction from him and to listen to
him talk.
Why?
Why wouldn't,
I mean he figured a lot things out.
The key is a lot of us don't have a sort of the Meta cognition medical where I
want to see if he runs on his toes though.
I need to see that ball of the foot.
So let's,
let's try a couple of conversations.
All the footage.
Good Ball.
Let's be clear.
Let's see how he's running.
There was either running or not running.
He'll first man,
that guy's breast out.
He's hitting the hill first.
No Way.
That's going to stop that running crazy.
That guy is flat footed.
When he's landing,
he is running terrible.
Your foot raised flat footed is okay.
What's not okay?
Ball of the foot strikes first.
That's not okay.
That's okay.
There's some variation that what he's doing it well.
It's hard to tell I'm talking to,
it's not hard to tell him he's moving really fast.
I'm talking shit.
I mean it might have been what I call the foot.
Here's,
here's what I would think.
It's his arms or hands on.
To me that's less efficient.
What's going on there?
What's all that about?
Unstable.
Unstable,
so unstable.
And that's what he's,
he's looking for.
He's like,
that's how he uses his I kido though.
He's all,
he's like with like,
oh,
so you mean practice makes permanent?
Does that what practices at a whole bunch and that's the only way.
So even when he runs,
he's got that sort of whipping motion going on with his arms.
It kind of makes sense.
So when we teach people to run,
we say,
hey,
pretend like you're grabbing two chips.
Right?
Put your shoulders in this position.
It's extra rotate position makes your shoulder stable.
It creates stability in the head.
What you'll see is that people around you chips man chips,
like you have to potentially have some cross the chips.
Two of them.
Imagine that you're grabbing something else and you don't,
you want to be gentle.
Right,
right.
Can you say,
can you say my name like coke?
I don't understand.
Like put your elbows tight.
No,
no.
This is this how she'd be running.
You're just,
you're just holding on,
holding on to the ships.
This is how you'd run to protect those checks.
Where was his gout hands going across his body.
How much force is he given away?
All of that.
So my hands coming across,
I've got to stop it.
It's a heavy load.
I want to minimize that.
When you see kids running with their elbows out.
Right.
Like
RTD too.
You're right.
That's a test that c three Po runs with his arms out.
Yeah.
What is the r two d two doesn't have arms.
I'm just letting you talk to him.
All right,
I'll try it.
See if your hero,
well,
senior here.
I'm fine.
Um,
so rewinding,
you were talking about squeezing that butt early.
We're coming back.
So the,
the issue is do you um,
know how to run right?
If you take people's shoes off,
they run the same way people or designed for evolution,
that means you probably have one running pattern that you would do slow and
fast.
You wouldn't have one running pattern that you would do slow and a completely
different movement pattern that you would do when you sprint.
You'd be able to cycle up and down.
We know what the injury running rates are.
You can't,
he'll strike,
every kid is born with their heel flat on the ground,
not entitled to shoes.
So running is running the way you would run barefoot.
You can get away with a heel striking if you're running on soft surfaces,
right?
Yeah.
Right.
If I can make all these conditions I have,
I have my hundred and $50 shoes and my inserts and I run on a soft surface or a
treadmill and I can run like this until I can't write.
You should be able to ring.
You're designed to be 110 years old when you designed to be pain free for that
hundred 10 years.
Yeah,
that's it.
So when you start to wear a hole in your kneecap,
cause you've been heel striking,
that heel comes down,
the whole quad loads,
knee comes forward,
quits a ton of sheer.
You were holding your kneecap,
you see your doctor and doctors like,
oh she stopped running.
And you say things like,
well you know you're the worst doctor ever.
You're not allowing me to express myself through my running.
This is bs.
Well and that's the same thing.
Well the doctor saying something,
you're reasonable.
Hey you're moving like crap.
You've destroyed your body.
Something's got to change.
That heals tracking happen because of a shoe designer.
That's 100% right.
That is so strange.
If you really stop and think about that,
how many people run like that heel down first and it all came about because of a
shoe design.
This up,
kids don't heel strike until about the first grade.
No kid under the first grade.
So new a of Christmas,
heel strikes,
they all run beautifully.
Then they go home at Christmas break and half of them ask for heel strike for
Christmas.
And then what happens is they've started sitting long enough,
you know,
you know what sitting does,
your body travel feels wretched,
but it's okay for our kids to sit eight hours a day.
It was hard to all the,
all the kids coaches who coach young kids and they all say the same thing,
they're so short in the hip,
they all move like crap.
We have to undo the sitting from the day before we can even get any work done.
So we also start to shorten their heel cords.
So when we make this joke about Chinese flip binding rights,
archaic,
but you're designed with your feet flat on the ground.
And then what we do is we start to systematically lift that heel up.
Like the shoe I'm in has a four millimeter drop or three or four millimeter
drop.
That's still a high heel shoe.
It's not flat.
So if we look at some people's Nike's or some of these other shoes,
they have upwards of a centimeter and a half,
which is a basically a high heel shoe,
right?
So we're walking around like shortening the heel cord,
Which means I take away your ankle range of motion and suddenly you start to
figure out how I can walk with my feet.
Turned out a little bit.
It makes my ankles more effective with this shortened he'll court position if I
take that body and I said,
okay,
here's a stable young kid,
brilliant spine,
right young,
we're doing gymnastics and I just can't the whole thing forward a centimeter and
a half from the bottom that projects out over the spine of the kid,
maybe two centimeters,
three cinemas to the whole kid center mass is forward.
And because you're a human being,
you'll just compensate for it.
So we start to adopt these patterns,
the same patterns that if I'm texting in this crappy position,
my my upper back is rounded.
That means when I look up,
so if I look at like a simple position,
like if I've just kind of round in text,
I picked my head up,
my head's naturally level because my eyes were going to always,
you know,
get to the horse horizon line.
But if I stay up,
look what my position,
my head is it right?
I didn't change the neck position,
I changed my upper back position.
So now I'm having this kind of car accident and my cervical spine,
my neck,
or I get lower cervical flection,
Kook,
upper cervical extension.
And not only does this without this and cause osteophytes,
but it's less effective position when you take a shot to the head or we need to
generate force.
Your body prioritizes that nervous system above all other things.
And you know this,
when you injured your back,
how stoked are you to have wild sex?
You still want to have wild sex,
but you weren't stoked,
right?
Right.
Because your back hurts so bad.
You injure nervous system.
My athletes go down,
I got like it takes me,
it's gonna take me two days.
If it's just a stupid spinal fault,
a little tweak to days to turn the whole thing where I've lost two days of
training.
Most time it takes a couple of weeks right before you start feeling like you
want to drag force again.
Three weeks now you're behind.
You're behind all of my other athletes tweak your nervous system for real heavy
leg.
Go numb.
Your body is shutting you down because it's such a primary threat to who you are
as a human being.
You have a brain to move you through the environment so you can interact with
your environment.
That's the whole reason that the nervous system developed in the animal to just
reproduce itself.
You can feed,
you can fight,
you can run away.
When you,
when you trashed that nervous system,
your body prioritizes it in a big way.
In fact,
cognition,
all of the high order thinking,
the human being has been,
it's called the neo cortex has been bootstrapped on top of the movement brain.
So it's not an accident that like,
Hey,
I have a meditation practice and a movement practice,
right?
I have to have to be a really good thinker.
I have to also train hard.
Well,
it's because these systems are totally integrated into disintegrate them to get
away from the movement and just go be a piece of meat on the,
on the treadmill or the elliptical machine does human beings a disservice.
So that's saying essentially the really brilliant people who don't take care of
their body are brilliant.
Again,
in spite of the fact,
well it's because we're not reaching their full potential engineering.
So good.
But what about a good amount of time that takes a developed skill as opposed to
the amount of time that it takes to,
uh,
spend doing physical training,
like teaching someone the martial art for example.
Now you only have like four days a week to train.
How many days a week would you train this guy in or this gal in,
in,
in physical movement,
and how many days would you let them go to kickboxing class or go to Jujitsu
class?
The idea here is that those aren't disparate separate systems.
It's the same movement,
right?
Like it's not in a lot of positions like rubber guard,
there's,
there's triangles,
there's a lot of like weird,
you know,
positions where these are,
these are very odd positions with your feet tucked under people's Chins and pull
on your foot sideways,
you know?
But it's,
but it's really not
that weird.
If you,
if I teach you like we're not doing pull ups,
I'm teaching you to create a stable pull off of the bar.
Right.
That's what this is really quite good in what I'm saying.
What I'm saying is that the amount of time that it takes to get awesome at that,
the amount of time to get that shit.
Okay.
Are got it.
I got repetition in,
in the techniques.
So I went over.
I totally got it.
But you you're saying it could be better saying
that I had the skills,
I'm teaching in the strength conditioning as a side effect.
I become fit as a side effect of become stronger,
should integrate and support 100% of the training you're doing.
And the other side,
the promise,
we're like,
oh this is my training,
this is my conditioning and strength work.
It's the same work my,
and then what ends up happening is that you'll,
you'll have a stronger trunk,
you'll be able to generate force from these worst positions.
You'll be able to recover more quickly.
Skill takes a long time to develop.
So what we're asking is,
you know,
are you skilled?
Are you going,
where are you gonna put your,
your eggs in the basket?
You should probably be skilled in all of your movement and the,
all of those movements,
skills translate in how many times you need to.
You people definitely get this messed up.
The most important thing to do to get good at a sport is your sport,
right?
That's people are,
you know like if you are going to be a fighter,
you better do a lot of fighting.
Then I just need to know enough strength conditioning to fit in the holes.
Like if you do,
if you go fight right and wrestle and fight and do all the things,
your conditioning is pretty stellar.
You probably don't need to do a whole bunch of extra conditioning because you've
just did that on the ring.
I'll have to do is fight a bunch of people.
Once you understand how conditioned you need to be.
But I do need a systematic way to uncover your limitations and that's why today
we're going to deadlift and and so some of the things we do even three times a
week or twice a week is enough to sort of recover or uncover the positional
missing.
So I can see it.
How do we make the invisible visible?
One thing is that these master coaches can see you fight and be like,
that guy is really good.
I don't know what it is.
And let me give you an example.
My,
I have a six year old daughter.
We call bear,
she is the most legit human being I've ever met and she's wired the way I dream
about being wired as a kid.
Like she's just like she.
And so there's this old school Olympic lifting coach named Mike Bergner who is
the man.
He lives down in San Diego.
He's been Olympic lifting and longer than dinosaurs.
He saw Caroline move at an early kid and he's like,
you will send me Caroline,
she will live at my house in the summers.
She is an Olympic champion.
How do you decide that while she stands forward,
she creates a lot of torque automatically.
She's organized well or heads balance,
right?
She moves in the same way that your coaches would walk down the hall and be
like,
Hey,
you play soccer kid,
we should play.
You know,
or it's someone grabbed you because you know you do these things.
So what I'm saying is we've got to keep developing these skills and uncovering
the problems because if you just fight all the time,
you're going to end up looking like a fighter and you'll adopt to these
positions.
And it's hard to sort of systematically uncover the problems still come back to
the shoulder if you're going to be an wretched position,
but you're missing range of motion,
you don't have the control and the positioning,
you will sacrifice position in that bad position and that's where you start to
get injured because you get dumped on your shoulder.
That's where you're generating torque,
that's where the guy breaks your grip because you're in these untenable
positions and you're compromised in those untenable positions.
That's a,
that's very fascinating.
How would you figure out how to schedule the time?
Would you say what would be most important?
Most important is a skill and then right after that would be strength and
conditioning.
So would you just,
you would limit it to like one out of four training sessions.
Like say if you only had four training sessions a week,
one out of four,
three of them,
or let's divide them up and let's give me,
give me two,
give me two 20 minute sessions and how would you organize it?
What'd you do?
Like the really hard physical training like the first day of the week and then
do the other three days skill or would you do the other the opposite?
Well,
I think that is the law.
That's the conversation between your coach and you were,
and that's really why you need coaching,
right?
So,
but what I'm thinking getting at is should you be exhausted while you're
learning the physical movements?
Well,
do when you do
skills,
when are you best learning the skills when you're totally exhausted,
when you're fresh,
right?
So if we're going to do high value pieces where I'm teaching a skill,
I want my athletes pretty fresh in there,
right?
I've got to look at the volume.
This is,
this is the art of coaching.
My job,
especially as a strength conditioning coach and physical therapist is never is
to enhance the strength,
the fighting of the sport in my athlete.
So if you're blown up and you can't fight,
and what am I doing?
Right?
There's also skill to learning how to train when you're exhausted.
And that's one of the reasons why some people like to put guys through physical
training first different and take them through soul.
Totally different feel content,
but Hackleman do rolling wrassling right row 500 have a fresh guy beat the crap
out of you.
It was good.
Yeah,
it seems like it's not a good idea but it's a good idea.
Great idea.
And then do it again and have another fresh guy beat the crap out of it.
It also teaches you how to keep your shit together when you're falling apart.
When your body's physically Paul Fon apart,
teaches you how to at least conserve and enough energy and distribute it.
Like to know like,
okay,
we can't go full blast right now but we can go,
I can go right now at 40% full clip and then in 30 seconds I'll be back.
So in my gym,
my laboratory,
there was always some stimulus load combination where I'm going to exceed your
capacities.
Is it going to be so heavy or so long?
So many reps or so you're going to be breathing so hard that you start to break
down and the job is to spend the time at the margins of those experience,
right?
So to know Nongo fully in where you're not in control of your body and you're
going to get hurt.
I mean,
is that,
is that how you're going to be successful?
No.
If I blow myself out,
I'm gonna get my ass kicked.
I agree 100% but why is it that there's like a lot of meat head thinking when it
comes to that as opposed to just fool could keep going.
Pusy pick it up and while your legs are malfunctioning,
by the way,
these are awesome.
We should really take that word back.
Like if you come in she'd be like,
thanks man.
I have a pussy.
Let's just kidding.
It is a weird thing.
Like how did that ever get to be bad?
We start saying Sally,
like we're changing it.
We're taking the word pussy back.
Heck it.
Same with Dick.
Girls Love Dick,
but they don't like a guy who was a dick.
It's basically the same thing.
That's what we say,
cock cock.
What?
We're so weird with that.
You're right.
I'll say it's fine the whole time.
We need to be skilled.
We talk about training age,
right?
It takes a long time to know your capacities.
It takes a long time to know yourself as an athlete and have a coach.
No you,
that's the balance.
That dynamic between trainer and athlete,
between coach and athlete.
What you're saying too is,
you know you keep saying trainer an athlete,
but I think what you're saying really is applicable for just human beings and I
think that's one of the most important aspects of teaching a kid young,
some sort of sport,
like giving them sort of a sense of how it feels to move your body and
competition.
So 100% right?
Like you have to be stressed.
We have to put you,
if you don't ever compete or fight or perform music like standup comedy is the
same thing as fighting.
It's the same thing as competing.
Like stimulus is the same mental state as the same conscious.
You have to,
I got to stop you right there.
No,
it's not even close.
You don't think,
you know,
you don't think like being aware of the room and what's going on?
Oh No,
no,
no.
It's not even,
it's not even remotely near as scary.
It's not even remotely dangerous.
How,
here's the thing,
we need to come and stand up comedy.
You can essentially control the entire situation.
If you're prepared and you have your material together,
he doesn't that sound like exactly what you're trying to,
you're trying to always control the entire situation.
That fight.
You try to,
I agree,
but don't you try to train controls many things.
You can,
as you sure you tried to keep all your ducks in a row and get your conditioning
together,
but if you're fighting a bad motherfucker,
you're in for some danger.
There's no,
there's no getting out of that and stand standup comedy.
What's the worst thing that happens?
You don't laugh like the ideas are completely different.
It's for a lot of people,
they have this weird thing and mental state is the same.
You don't think the the again lutely not,
it's absolutely not because you,
you can think about a lot of other things before you go on stage.
I can pal around with friends,
I can joke around with people I've competed before and I was fucking,
I was in a world of my own before I went out there.
I knew that I can't have people talk to me.
I don't want to see,
I'm visualizing what I'm going to do.
I can't be having like little bullshit conversations and then go out there and
fight cause you'll get kicked in the face.
It's a completely different things.
I go,
look,
it's so relaxed.
You get good at it.
You know how the fucking thing works.
You just get out there and do it.
Well.
Okay,
so pull that aside.
Let's say that you've got loose you tons of reps,
but performance is performance.
And the,
the idea though is we should put kids in these stressful situations to,
to teach them about their own heads.
They should sing,
they should learn how to compete because they find out about what it,
where they break down,
what their metal.
That's the part of the reason we do sport in the first place.
I learned how to compete.
I think the worst people to be around are people that never learned how to
compete.
They also don't learn how to lose.
They don't learn how to learn that you need more to learn.
Like you could be fucking amazing at chess,
but not even know how to play go.
You know when someone brings this thing out and you're like,
what is this?
Fuck I tell your ass kicked and go.
You gotta know what you,
you know things and you don't know things.
And the only way to find that out to really find that out is through competition
to really be told,
boom,
you just got crushed at this video game.
You don't know how to play this shit at all.
Let me hit you back on it.
So if you're,
if you're really funny with your friends and someone's like,
you should be calm,
you start speaking,
you're not really a comic to stand up in front of a bunch of strangers and do it
right.
You're not really a comic until you get banned from the comedy store.
That's when you become a real calm.
They ban you at least once.
I was paying twice.
So if you're a,
if you're a kid though or a,
you know,
you at some point,
if you're a musician and you never play,
I thought I hear you 100%.
You,
you must put yourself through some stress to figure out what to do when it
happens because otherwise it's an an,
an overwhelming amount of stimuli and energy and adrenaline and it's hard to
manage.
Do you watch the tapes of you performing comedy afterwards?
Sometimes I do too.
The more that I watched her do something,
so some of that's after action.
So it's your pro and you're really good at it.
But what about,
do fighters look at the tapes after they fight?
I think a lot of them do.
Yeah.
A lot of them because there's a lot of data.
They're most stressed out itself.
I got to see what I did and I was tired and getting my ass kicked.
Like,
see,
there's a lot of data there.
Yeah.
Without a doubt.
And I think a lot of guys,
you look at videos of their training as well,
and that's a very beneficial,
there's a lot of times you realize that you're doing something funny and you
didn't realize it.
Like,
you know,
like I know what a guy looks like,
what he's,
he's really good at Moyie Thai.
I know how he moves,
but if I looked at myself I'd be like,
Oh,
I'm moving kind of goofy.
You know?
I would be able to see in a video just through trainings,
like little errors that you can't see while you're actually doing it.
So I feel like,
let's take this back to the pain.
Let's spin it back to common stuff.
Right.
Do you have an understanding of what your processes with your spine?
You're talking to him,
he doesn't understand shit.
Trust me.
I understand.
No,
no.
So what ends up happening?
It's like,
it's like fighting and fighting and getting the same results over and over
again.
And Ela twice a year.
I got my ass kicked twice here,
get my ass kicked.
But I'm not really paying attention to the details.
What I'm telling people is that we can resolve a lot of crap.
It's not clear.
What is it?
Oh cider.
We can resolve a lot of the crap.
We can take a lot of the crap off the table.
That was an energy drink.
Sorry.
No,
no.
They take a lot of crap off the table.
I apologize if holes twice this week.
I've done that shit.
If you have a list,
if you,
uh,
if you can make the invisible visible.
So one of the things that I want coaches in that and athletes understand is that
it's hard to see some of these tendencies.
It's hard to see some of these things in the gym.
If I expose you to some of these movements,
I can tell where you're giving away force and then you can tell her you're being
inefficient,
right?
Because the hip is the hip,
whether you're kicking or squatting,
it's the same similar position.
So you think you could enhance someone's like kicking and punching power even
while the guy who's like really good.
Yes.
I mean we,
I have,
I have met only a couple people who have been what I consider in the 90% like
who,
just who are just wiring and not have a lot of efficiency left to be gained.
The system,
and I'm not talking about skill,
right,
right.
You still got gotta train.
You still gotta be conditioning still gotta show up and perform.
But I'm not saying that this is a done deal,
but be harboring back to our kids thing.
How do we create this ready state where this kid was a set of skills.
So my daughter's swim,
right?
This is one of the,
teaches them so much about positioning.
They do gymnastics,
they swim,
they do a ball sport.
Like this is the language,
but also there's some formal movement training in there that's in the sense the
formal movement training in the swimming,
we have to create a language and arc type so that kids can understand whether
they're aware of what the shoulder needs to be doing at age.
They still know how to turn the IPAD on and off.
That's all it makes sense.
You know,
cause I'm not a very good athlete at all.
Like I've,
I'm a black belt in taekwondo and a black belt in Jujitsu,
but like I don't know how to do other sports.
Like I don't,
I don't do them.
Well I can't ice skate.
Like you put me on some ice caves,
I fall,
he put me on some skis.
I look retarded.
That's about training.
So that's,
that's the fallacies about my whole,
my whole life I didn't do any sports.
All I did was martial arts.
So my body developed that way and it knows how to move that way.
But if,
if so take,
I mean there's nothing natural but I skating or skiing,
my kids fucking skate the shit out of it.
There's spinning around behind it.
Did it,
did it your old learn how to fucking ski like that Dude and it,
I'm,
I'm all awkward and shit plastic figuring it out.
Right.
I'm trying to,
my posture sucks.
I don't want to look at the neuroplasticity of the brain.
When is,
when is it becomes difficult to pick up new skills when you're old and fucked
up.
Like,
man,
especially with bad motor patterns,
right?
It's hard to undo the BS.
So if you're,
if you're,
if you tell me,
hey,
I have this fighter this way does he goes and we tie,
I mean I drive past with ice cream,
getting my cream for my kids.
I drive past that and my school every single day people in there,
that's probably pretty great.
All around healthy fitness,
breathing hard,
going to feel great sort of things and tell what you break.
So let's just say that you have a lot of imbalances when,
especially when you're doing boxing so much left side,
your left side gets like,
that's why we 50% more work than your rights.
That's 100% right.
So my golfers who turned one direction for living,
the fighters who lead with the left,
I'll tun,
that shouldn't be a surprise.
I should start looking for more dysfunction on the left side.
Stiffness on the left side.
The hip doesn't turns effectively on that right side because I'm punching off it
over and over and it gets stiff.
So if you can understand the positions you can program to it,
and that's the sort of the second half is it sometimes people's biomechanics
gets messed up.
Your tissues are just stiff,
your joint capsule,
stiff.
You physically can't get into the good position because you're doing it a lot.
Then what do you do about it?
And so if we give the basic tools,
they can turn it around.
It's weird how like you'll have one side that's like tightened up,
like you'll be able to throw a kick with your right leg and it's just a real
smooth and easy.
But then when you're left leg there's like this herky Jerky,
like it's awkward,
it doesn't turn over all the way.
So if you,
if I watched you squatting and be like,
that's the side,
it's all messed up,
right?
You would be able to see right away get into a pistol.
I'm like,
ah,
look at that hip.
You can see it.
That's,
so the,
the formal language of strength conditioning makes things easier to see if you
recognize that left side to right side and try to mobilize that position right.
Address all of the systems and you're moving correctly will,
chances are you can probably fix it without even doing that.
Squatting the squatting makes it easy to see.
It also builds efficiency in the system.
You know what's also weird,
when you practice something lefthand,
it actually shows you there's actual data to show that you get better with your
right side as well.
Like there's something about practicing opposite handed in certain things that
actually allows your mechanics to improve with your dominant hand.
It's because it's called deep practice with throwing.
Yes.
Teachers who throw with their left hand,
it actually improves their right handed pitcher.
She cause you're so conscious of your PR,
the thought patterning and how it feels.
You've thrown a million times to the right hand.
You throw snowballs at me.
You're not even paying attention to me.
You're watching over here.
Right.
But all of a sudden your tenants left hangup,
right?
The left hand,
the left handed.
I'm that way with pool.
I could play the shit out of some right-handed pool,
but I get it in my left hand and I barely know how to like move my arm.
Like I've been playing bill pull all my life.
My right arm is loose and fluid.
My left arm was all fucked up and I can't get it to go straight.
It's amazing practice.
Oh,
the shooting range that is pushing with your right hand.
Amazing.
Cool Shit with your left hand is terrible,
but it looked so gangster.
Just be shooting something.
I'm going to use my right hand son.
So we,
some of our,
uh,
our Ninja friends tried that.
They went like the pet rescue guys and they're like,
uh,
you know,
the,
they just emptied out on,
they're like,
they can't hit anything there.
Like if someone shows you a puzzle like this,
you're pretty safe.
Yeah.
Unless he's like right in front of me.
They miss a lot.
Those guys,
that's a problem.
Right?
That's a problem in the eye.
Look with this position is check this out.
Solid as far right.
Well,
what position is that?
that's the rope climbing positions and positions.
So what color truck?
If your head is neutral and I'm controlling the area,
there's my lock off position.
Extra rotate,
extra rotate.
Extorts boom.
Right?
And I can reload.
I'm writing here.
I can see what's going on around me.
This is how the queen waves,
she waves in that same position.
Why it's stable.
You can wave like this all day.
She goes like,
no,
she doesn't.
She goes,
you knuckles.
That's like,
bitch,
I don't even have to turn my fucking hand around.
We'd see.
We call this the royal too.
We call this the backhand at five because you can back hand high five someone.
It's more stable and sanitary.
She really waves like that.
That is rude.
You poop on your hand,
rude when you feel like,
first of all,
you feel so fucking lucky that you were the queen.
I mean who gets to be the queen?
You didn't like go to school for it because you're just a fucking queen.
Everyone at home,
at home wave like this.
So lucky you're all symbol.
Be So rude.
Now.
Wave like this wave like this and going to be hired.
It feels unstable and you should be so happy for the queen should be bowing.
She'd be so happy.
Blowing kisses,
check,
check this out.
If you grab,
you know,
drinking with the pinkies up.
Right.
We say pinkies up.
What does that,
what does that really a cue to do?
So yeah,
that's what it looks like.
It looks like I'm about to give a go and take this.
So if uh,
the sprinters run with their hands out wide,
right.
With the fingers out.
Right.
Cause it creates stiffness.
The elbow.
That makes sense.
What's the extensor stuff?
Or Tony Blauer is extensor extensor power.
If you put the,
the handout,
you're crit stiffness.
Well that's what you're really doing with the pinky.
So people figured it out over and over again that pinkies out crates,
stiffness.
Next time you're drinking the high tea with the Queen,
put your fingers in your bail,
shake your fingers out.
Legit.
That's interesting.
You know,
it would be,
it's,
it's such a fascinating thing like learning how to stabilize and put the human
body into the optimum position.
And that thinking of that as a something,
an education,
you think of that as a,
uh,
something that can be taught to people.
Oh,
it has to be observable,
measurable and repeatable.
If we work with me and we get better,
the only way we can measure it is we can measure wattage and poundage and output
did fighting positions.
That's right.
We can measure it.
And if it doesn't improve that,
then what the hell are we doing?
Let me ask you this.
So if you were allowed to organize a children's athletics in schools,
and I will be education and going after it,
oh,
are you really?
What do you,
what's the plan like what do you,
what did,
what would you do once you got in there?
Would you just teach kids proper ways of movement?
I mean,
it would it be require a one on one with kids and,
and here's the deal is that we have somehow mystified all of that.
So we've gutted your,
we've gutted your school.
My Kids' school gets nine out of 10 stars.
We live in Marin county.
It's dope school.
That's a beautiful place.
Just beautiful.
We live in San Rafael and it's nine out of 10 stars,
but she gets a half hour of PE once a week,
like nine out of 10 stars.
That's okay.
She comes home and she's like,
Dad,
we did dodge ball today.
You would hate it.
I didn't learn anything.
You know they're allowed to do dodge ball though.
I like that.
We try and take that shit away.
No,
but that's,
that's called recess.
Dodge ball is not teaching skills.
So what we teach is this really rudimentary stuff.
He can you and there's some basic archetypes for the,
for the body.
Can you bend over and pick something up?
Can you squat correctly?
Can you learn?
Can you run correctly?
Boom.
Can you lunch?
I mean those,
those are the basic shapes of the hip.
So let me ask you this.
If you,
if you had a guy like Tim Sylvia,
again,
we established great fighter and he's in his thirties and he has this way of
standing with his toes pointed in.
Why did he figure toys planner?
What'd that allowed him to do?
Create even more torsion off of the ground.
So when his toes are in,
he can create even more grip and torque in those basic shapes.
He's figured out that that that toe in position allows him to be more stable and
functional.
So how would you fix that though?
What would you have him do that would correct something like that.
The issue is,
is he doing that because that's the only reason.
Only way he can move and it,
boy,
if he didn't have full range of motion in his hip for example,
right.
That's the problem.
So as soon as you give,
if you teach athletes,
so they're doing their skill lights,
hang on.
If you teach skills,
cause this is,
this is messes with people's minds.
If you're a skilled athlete and you're training and doing all the drills and all
the things,
if I improve your range of motion,
you instantaneously use it.
You'll suck it up and use it.
And I,
I did this with like some,
some fighters hips that were in guard,
I gave them,
showed them how to mobilize and I mobilize them into better positions in guard.
And literally they ended up in a stronger position because they used it right
away.
So hands in internally rotates you and puts you into an unstable position.
W We,
you just said,
I just started thinking about it.
If you point your toes forward,
it does open your hips up a little bit,
but allows you to create a little bit their grip.
If you stand up and see how stable you are,
it's a righteous position with your feet.
Turned out that that's not a good athletes.
Louie Simmons Best Powerlifter on the planet coaching.
He would choose athletes and be like,
oh that guy's walking with his feet straight.
It's going to be good athlete.
Wow.
And how simple is that?
Walk with your feet straight.
So listening to this tomorrow,
wake up and walk their feet straight.
So any guy who has his toes or any Gow who has their toes point forward,
it's not,
they can turn it out.
Yeah,
well sometimes.
Sometimes there.
And so we,
we go upstream,
we look at his pelvis.
If he's in a bad lower spine position,
then that's the only position he can get his in.
If he his feet,
if his pelvis is overextended.
So one of the things that we've got to teach people,
what do you prioritize?
First we prioritize nervous system for the reasons we talked about,
which includes the relationship between your pelvis and your and your spine,
which is the best position to kick in a,
we were just,
I was just looking at,
uh,
a great,
tennis player and he's just completely straight up and down organized toes
pointed in the net.
Like it's,
it's,
or you know,
as he slams the ball,
it's cause that he figured out that was the most position,
position,
more fish efficient position.
So if,
if we organize the hip,
what we see is that if your trunk is disorganized and people out there have a
ton of shoulder pain,
if you're rounded through your upper back,
you cannot control your shoulders effectively.
You lose power,
you lose position,
you lose mechanics.
For example,
we teach,
I work with a lot of pictures,
but that's how a lot of guys punch.
That's fine.
Punch like that.
And optimal,
it's different.
And think it's to Glenn pick up their mind.
Glenn does that.
Yeah.
So just tell me what you like your eyes when you're looking at,
let me just show first that punching.
So fighting,
it's not necessarily the best expression of human movement,
right?
Okay.
But I need to be able to go in and out of these positions and I can still
generate force from this position.
But if this is the only position I can be in,
then my shoulders are going to be compromised.
Oh,
okay.
So you're saying that not doing it occasionally.
Occasionally.
That's fine.
But it has to be,
go ahead and,
okay,
go ahead and swim or jump off something or like you're going to have to be you
that capacity.
Right?
I'm not asking people to walk around like ballet dancers are dead lifters in
this formal position.
That's the best way to teach the principle.
I thought you were saying was never going to them.
No,
that's ridiculous.
I need to be able to come in and out position out of that position.
Right.
But if I'm stuck and I have one choice,
which is that position than I've limited my capacities of limited.
My abilities have limited my options.
So if you jump and land in your knees,
come in,
you can't go any lower.
You can't,
you can't dip any drug.
You can't change directions.
You can't jump higher.
Right.
So when someone says the guy's pigeon toed always got poured genetics,
that's incorrect.
I would say that that's incorrect.
So even though that like families will have pigeon toed,
it's really just them watching each other walk and choosing to walk the mirror
neuron.
It's the thing you never even want to consider that.
Watch kids walk exactly what their dads were always thought it was a genetic
thing.
What?
What about he figured out if he walked in?
So some of these guys flat feet though.
So that feed is a genetic condition.
Is it not?
Why is it flat?
Why his mother has it and I have it so I have,
it's like the clap.
The flat.
So here's the deal.
But I mean I can move on.
The balls of my feet are moving the balls of my feet.
Well that's not the problem.
I bet.
I've always got 100 bucks.
Anyone I have never seen.
I've never not been able to create an arch in someone.
So how do you train an arch?
The system,
the whole body of bays,
these basic principles that when my foot's on the ground and I create torsion
through the hip,
the whole system winds up and become stable.
So for example,
I see what you're saying and you say give shitty posture of the feet.
It's why.
Yeah.
Right.
So if you squat or run and you collapse your arches,
is that a win?
No,
that's,
that's a fundamental breakdown and patterns that take long time to change.
It takes two years to turn over all the connected in your bio,
your Fascia,
two years.
So if,
if I screw my foot into the ground,
then the mechanics,
the Fascia,
the arch,
the bony structures,
pick up the arch and the whole system becomes more stable.
So if you take your middle finger,
put it over your pointer finger on your right hand,
that's input,
put it down.
That's your ACL on the front.
Got It.
Aco.
So ACL comes in,
it's interior,
interior,
cruciate ligament,
taches into your Tibia,
right.
If I externally rotate that thing right or anchor down?
No,
it becomes stable.
X,
oh external winds up and become stable.
What happens when I turn your foot out?
Okay.
If I was going like this and I actually rotate,
Bam,
the,
the thing becomes tighter,
right?
If I turn your foot out and move that,
what happens to your ACL and unwinds and becomes more slack,
right?
If your knee comes in,
what happens to your ACL?
It unwinds,
it becomes more slack.
So the question is what's the best position to create the most force?
And that's usually a lot more straight foot.
I have a little breathing room in there cause I can move around and I'm
adjusting to the universe.
But we know that when the foot starts to turn out past that I can measure your
hip function.
I can squeeze your knees and you can't create any tours in that position and it
exposes you to more injury cause he,
your mechanics start to fall apart,
including the structures of your feet.
Wow.
So what do you do to get a guy like me who's had flat feet for his whole life?
How do you,
how do you get me to how to heal?
What do I think?
High Hill.
Well,
what color red.
You had a picture of me with my shiny.
So trashy did glittery.
What do I do?
My nose is somebody's dirty bitch.
If I was a chick though,
come on.
Seriously.
What Red Glitter?
No,
I would like you in a blonde wig.
I think pink lipstick and Red Hill.
So are there any specific exercises that um,
develop?
Uh,
yeah.
Okay.
Punching,
punching,
jumping in.
I mean,
I mean like squirrel jumping and landing screen my feet into the ground.
Squatting,
teaching,
dead lifting.
That's why it's so easy to teach these very formal movement principles under
high load high.
And I reinforce them,
the,
the drills that people do.
So this is I think a good,
a good case.
Think about when you were in high school,
how many drills you did before you were actually allowed to scrimmage college.
It gets worse.
Like you do drills,
drills,
and if you're lucky you get to scrimmage.
So what that really is is practice,
practice,
practice.
Well,
let's just take the practice idea down,
not did you complete the task?
Yes or no,
but were you in the best position possible?
Yes or no?
Well,
the coach has this discrete amount of time to get something done.
It's hard to teach the basics yet.
Sometimes we have to,
we still teach elbows into kids right when they're blocking because we don't
want to get their arms take taken off.
Well,
it turns out when we do air squats or squat,
for example,
warming up,
we teach the keep the arms in because it becomes the default motor pattern.
So this is my stable position.
It's also funny that that's in a dominant position in wrestling.
I mean it's essentially double under hooks.
I mean you're,
you're,
you're getting a guy under like this.
You can control the body clamping down like this and what are you doing
decorating.
You can extra rotation,
torque off of both of those things instead of being up here.
Like if you have over hooks.
That's why when a guy,
when a guy has double under hooks on you and you have over hooks and you'd still
flip them,
you know like you,
you must be a bad mother.
He like,
there must be a big disparity in the grappling.
Well either that kid is really,
he's got his positions like John John's,
we'll do that shit to people.
He'll double over hook people and then send them sailing.
Look,
that guy's time is insane,
right?
It's physical intelligence,
physical intelligence and some of that is,
you know,
the train,
train,
train.
Also,
his form is,
he's got a very strange body,
you know,
I mean he's a very,
very strong kid,
but he's six foot four,
you know,
two 30 before he begins his cot and a long as Texas.
He's long as fuck.
So he's doing shit and getting like leverage that you just can't,
you can't compete with that shit.
But what's it cost in certain positions?
Who says position before submission?
Doesn't that sound familiar?
Everybody?
What his position then?
Well let's leverage this take.
They take it further than where you are.
The correct technique.
That's been assumed after,
you know,
hundreds of years or decades or whatever that has been of chesting competition
and it changes all the matches,
the physiology,
it matches the best position for the body in that,
that shape.
That's what it is.
It sort of does,
but sometimes it doesn't.
Sometimes it's not,
it's an awkward position but it works to get a guy in a,
in him in a vulnerable position.
Like there's a lot of submissions that are very actually like,
how about,
you know,
like gay teens like,
okay,
but how are you still creating torque?
There is more powerful if your shoulders back in a stable position like
[inaudible] versus being out here.
Yeah,
I guess Keith is not a good,
uh,
you know,
it's a great one.
Uh,
Nah that's not good.
Well,
let me give an example.
I was thinking,
I was thinking of clock jokes,
but I'm like,
no,
that's actually kind of
about how about a,
uh,
a real example from my firefighters.
So we got firefighters listen.
Okay.
One of the dirty tasks of the firefighters to pick people up off the ground
after,
after they,
after they've fallen off the toilet.
Right.
And one of the guys that are gym was the medical examiner for San Francisco.
So he,
he goes around the world and picks up dead people.
That's his job,
right?
He had a 350 pound woman die on the toilet.
She falls between the toilet and the wall.
I loved,
he's still,
so the question is,
can that guy get into a perfect position to pick that woman up off the ground?
Yes or no,
no way.
But what he can do is he can optimize his positioning as he tries to deadlift
that dead body up.
Right?
What about my first responders can people down the stairs,
like you can't be in a good position with the stretcher down the stairs.
So,
but they know how to protect themselves because of the straight do they do the
best of their can?
Because that's,
that's the positions that have been reinforced.
So the same thing happens.
You start to adopt these fundamental understanding shapes because they just
become rote and they also happen in mass to match the physiology.
Okay.
You know,
I disagree with you,
but then in practicing the techniques,
now I agree with you because there's like certain shit like I was thinking about
gay teens,
but the choking arm is this arm and essentially that's exactly where it goes.
It goes into that kind of a position.
I mean it's an awkward,
especially if you do the Denny Denny proper goes,
loves this grip.
Jake shields likes the script to where,
uh,
your,
your palms are facing outward.
So what's that allow you to do a ton of torsion?
Let me explain this to people.
If you're watching on iTunes,
you're,
if you're a right handed choker,
your palm,
your right palm is facing outward and you let Hans facing inward as you do the
choke,
it's,
it's a weird or odd odd position.
But what it does is the way it sets the bone up on the neck,
it's perfect.
It's like the perfect,
but it's odd.
It's fuck,
that's an honest fuck feeling to have your hands like this in this weird
position.
But if you get that,
it's incredibly strong.
But I disagree until I saw this.
The physiology is the same as if your shoulders in a good position,
then you're stronger from that business teen,
right?
And your shoulders forward,
shoulders rolled forward,
you don't have as much squeezing power.
You don't have the same amount of leverage to put into that versus if your
shoulders back and then you get your chest over there had collapse it and we're
able to get that,
that's a more stable position.
That's a better position.
So a person with a comprehensive understanding how the human body should move
like you when you could actually probably accelerate their ability to pick up
skills
100% and I'll tell you that like Forrest Griffin is a Ninja about his own
systems.
Like he understands,
hey,
I lifted heavy on this day before I trained.
I started sleeping in my bedroom,
right?
I have to be up.
I'm going to fight it.
11 o'clock he starts shifting his sleep patterns.
He's up at 11 he's exercising.
And 11,
all of those things are the same,
same language.
Do I have,
can I do them basic maintenance on myself?
Can I do the basic diagnostics on myself?
How do I measure these things?
That's,
that's the embodiment we're talking about.
And what's happened in the world now for the first time is that we have the
convergence of these systems and like it's all there.
It's really remarkable.
So,
all right,
I have an injury,
I have a back injury.
My,
uh,
I have a disc and like [inaudible] that's,
that's bulging.
It's been way better over the last couple months cause I took off a Jujitsu.
But all the other things that I do don't bother me.
The only thing that seems to bother his Jujitsu,
what,
what can I do besides trying to stand straight?
I've been doing that fucking Morgan on my posture.
It helps.
So we,
we'd get the pain out of your nerves.
So the first thing is we gotta get people out of pain.
I'm totally out of pain.
Zero pain.
The only when I wake up in the morning,
I'm a little stiff,
but I take a lacrosse balls and a I bridge on Rico lacrosse balls and I roll up.
Where did you hear that?
I found it online.
Is it you?
Is it your idea?
Was it congratulations or thank you brother.
I should congratulate him.
Let me get out of it.
I haven't married,
I have a jet with a Lacrosse ball in the back.
I um,
well that's,
listen man,
I read about it on some,
uh,
fitness forum.
I don't even remember,
but I didn't get no credit given to you,
so thank you.
Because that has helped me so much.
It's painful as fuck,
but I love it.
It's like a beautiful pain cause I know the relief that it's going to give me.
How do you know a tissue is normal?
This is good.
This doesn't hurt.
When your role at all,
it doesn't hurt.
You start to compress
massive.
I don't freak out and just see you're compressing my bicep.
It shouldn't feel like beef jerky and it shouldn't hurt.
So if you push on a tissue and it hurt,
it hurts.
It's not normal.
This is how I can prove that your system works.
My left side was where I got injured.
I have this weird left tweak and it's nothing.
It's not serious.
Like I right now I have zero hand pain,
nothing,
but when I get up in the morning it's very stiff and sometimes when I move
forward I can feel it.
When I take the Lacrosse ball and I and I and I bridge and I roll it up,
I don't feel shit.
I mean it's,
it's relaxed,
it's loose,
everything feels like it moves good.
And then one,
I always do it right before I train,
but I always do the left side.
So the other day I did the right side.
The right side isn't even injured and I was like,
ah,
right side was so fucked up.
It was more fucked up than the side that has a disc injury.
It was all knotted up tight.
Try My buzz.
That sucks.
Trying to stabilize,
trying to compensate for the left side,
being so fucked up.
The one of the problems I have is that people have made this like Voodoo.
Well,
your left foot is off and so your pelvis is,
what is that about?
It's misplaced precision.
Like we measure all of these golfers.
You ever talked to a raw for the hits you with that they
wouldn't rub your ribs is treating your toes out.
This is,
this is a little luckier.
Assist it.
Look,
I understand the connected tissue web like all my fast check kids out there.
This is a,
this is a little known fact about Kelly Star at,
I got married when I was 25 to a girl I dated in college.
Be playing music words,
you know,
she was a Rolfer.
Don't do the Hawk theme.
That's when the Hawk walks away.
I'm married a rifle by accident.
Nothing wrong with Ralph.
No,
no,
no.
Get me wrong.
The key about understanding that is that it's one,
it operates on one system and that's that connective tissue fascia system.
It doesn't teach you how to move,
does it?
No,
it does.
It does.
It work on the joint.
Capsule node is a work on the muscle stiffness?
No.
So the reason rolfing didn't cure squatting knee pain,
cancer is that it's still incomplete because it doesn't still as well.
If you have to teach people to move first and you have to take this approach.
When you're on the ball,
you're working on the soft tissue,
but you're also working on the rib joints.
You're also working on the thoracic joint.
So what happens is that you're stuck stiff because your t spine gets stiff.
It's what happens.
You start to improve that mechanics,
your head positioning changes.
The whole system up regulates,
I have been in surgeries where they have literally like they look at a guy's
knee and the knee looks like a bloody cave.
Like there are still lag Mites,
slag tights in there,
boulders in there and there's blood and there's no ACL and the physician is
like,
what the hell?
They pull out rocks and it pops out and when laughs,
well it turns out that guy doesn't have knee pain.
So the issue is that you're designed to be ridden hard and put away wet.
You are designed when you just get a picture.
I know so many world record holders and so many world champions who have
herniated discs that are asymptomatic,
they just don't hurt.
You'll recover that thing.
What you've lost is the,
the the right to be in shitty positions.
You've sort of kind of given up that right user,
get out of jail free card and now you're going to be more positional sensitive.
As you open up that thoracic spine,
he'll heal that disk.
One of friends.
How do you,
how does it heal the desk though?
If this just stand up straight,
it'll heal my desk.
Well,
Dis heal over time.
They're fairly bare,
poorly perfused,
which is a reason why you can't be inflamed all the time and run around.
You've got to set up the conditions for healing.
But theoretically you can't regrow an ACL or a bloody bone,
but you're designed to heal until you die.
So the real question is how are you optimizing that healing situation?
I have this little,
little formula,
right?
Lifestyle.
And that means you're dealing with your stress.
You're getting enough sleep.
And the people out here,
no,
they don't get enough sleep.
Sleep less than six hours a day.
You can be 30% immune compromised and your fasting blood glucose is up.
It's elevated or prediabetic like you had plus 30 pounds on you instantaneously
if you have right.
Lifestyle,
sleep,
nutrition,
hydration,
you're too,
and all those things plus correct movement,
you should be pain free and to continue to get better.
So we take that our athletes silver,
right?
Who's a 30 years old now,
he's a bit older.
Who?
Anderson?
No,
no.
Tim,
Silvia,
Silvia.
Right,
right.
We still like in his late thirties okay.
One of the things that I'm interested in is how do I extend the careers of these
great athletes because it takes a long time to become a good fighter.
Young kids in their 20s or genetic monsters,
they can,
they metabolically super fit,
freakishly talented and fast,
but by the time you're sort of in your 30s you have fought a lot.
You have a lot of experience,
but that's when your body starts to break down.
But you're really good when you're 34 you're really good when you're 35 why even
fighting for 25 years?
You're a soldier.
You're a tour de France guy,
you're a power lifter.
How do I extend your career?
How do I optimize the positions?
Because you can do it until you physically can't do it anymore.
Right?
Until you decide that I'm too slow or I'm not worth the training versus taken
out because my neck hurts or my back hurts and we're having this luck,
we're be able to extend guys' careers because we resolved their positions.
We get them into these better lifestyles where they're,
they're not eating the gluten,
they're drinking more water,
they're sleeping better.
So a lot of MMA fighters,
this is damaged,
this damage to the body.
That's 100% true.
Like that sport is going to accumulate some trauma.
But if I know how to kick correctly,
let's just say then when I kick you,
I turned the leg over.
One of the things that happens in the hip ends up in a more stable position.
Lemme lemme know,
give about a guy that,
uh,
I know that just retired recently.
Uh,
Shane Carwyn,
uh,
who's,
was a great fighter,
really beautiful guy,
just a really friendly,
brilliant guys.
Actually an engineer before he ever got an MMA and he had to retire because of
back injuries.
He's got stenosis and he's,
uh,
started to,
have an impingement on his nerves and he's had a couple of operations and uh,
he feels that a lot of this he got during football heavy collisions
completely.
So now he's stenotic and for those of you don't know what's to Gnosis is it
means your extension sensitive if you put your butt back like cheap stripper,
not a classy strip.
Hey,
easy Bray.
We don't judge on this show.
I'm not judging because when I'm in that position,
I'm the biggest strip in the room right now.
It's cheap.
That's cheap.
I'm just going to college.
Okay.
So when my,
when I overextend my pelvis to the low lumbar spine,
what I'm doing is I'm closing off those fossette joints.
I'm locking down what is the fossette joint?
It's the weight bearing doorstop of the,
of the,
of the spine.
So,
so at the bottom,
is that what it is?
Well,
it's in the back.
So what happens is if I take your elbow and slam it into extension over and over
again,
right,
right.
Eventually you can handle that.
But after a while that starts to hurt,
doesn't it?
You Damion to extension.
That's just one of the problems with Jujitsu.
Armbar always getting on gardening.
Serious arm problems.
That's right.
So it's the same thing for your back,
except the problem is that your back is set up to take billings of oscillations.
So it's,
it doesn't happen overnight and sometimes you're going to get dumped on your
head.
And that's called sport.
We,
that's that catastrophe.
Now,
let me ask you this though.
Do you,
when you see a guy that gets a serious back injury and then goes through
surgery,
do you think that's a mistake?
Steak?
Not always.
How often is it a mistake?
Well,
if the moving poorly still is moving poorly,
we don't have addressed the reason why he's had the promise,
not just catastrophic.
You just didn't,
you know,
get crushed one time dumped on your head.
Like,
you know,
you can get dumped on your head and herniated disc,
that's not your fault.
Right.
But the stenosis you know happen.
So he's saying,
hey,
it happened,
these high collisions,
what position was his back in when he collided?
These other kids,
we teach chest up to tackle ups.
Right?
Right.
Yeah.
Kids can't perform some of these basic squats and so they overextend in this
shape because they don't have this language and keeping the spine straight and
they basically end up defaulting to this bone on bone.
In all fairness though,
he's getting hit from the side by fucking gorillas.
This is,
this is not as simple as,
you know,
a guy having poor form,
but it's a lifetime of this.
But your aunt football,
the other guys talking slamming into each other.
I mean,
position matters more so.
I,
I have a bunch of kids who had a very,
I agreed does,
if you can control the situation,
but sometimes you can't.
When you're a football player you got to do,
it's coming out here on the side.
Do you think it's that one shot that takes him out or is it the repeated shots
that makes things a lot though.
You gotta take that into consideration when you're talking about 300 men who can
run,
you know,
they can do the hundred and what like four seconds.
You know this,
these are giant free Gash.
I freak athletes who was like a crash or their backs just blocking.
What about,
let's scale it down.
So we see kids in high school have that stenosis and you're obviously the expert
in this physical movement thing.
But I think you've got to take into consideration the physical trauma over the
300 pound guys running at you.
But this is what he's trying to say is if you're having that drama in a bad
position,
just going to have higher consequences.
So if that person,
true person,
say for example,
understands how to squat,
understands how it dealt with,
understands the proper organization of the spine,
and then that motor pattern is ingrained,
right?
So that's just a part of their wiring.
And then they go out on the football field and they're hitting in those good
positions.
Their chances of getting injured are a lot lower and say if they've developed
these bad positional right know habits,
right.
Running over excel right now.
Every time I get hit,
boom.
Now.
Now that's,
that's the bone on bone,
but there's also times where they get scissors.
Those hearts.
That's a lot of times what,
how God's get really badly injured fighting.
That's like Bo Jackson.
Right?
Absolutely stepping wrong.
I mean you can't control that,
but you can mitigate that by being in a good position or or training or,
but they are unusual and unique moments and you can't control which is sport
sport.
So a wrap them.
If I grab him,
Oh yeah,
here's the deal.
Keep.
This is the key understanding.
No one is being an ass here.
Everyone's working to the limits of their understanding.
No,
no one's saying you want no,
no wait.
I'm saying no.
I don't want to say I don't want to be an ass.
I want to,
I want to make sure that people understand that I think is that people are
working at the limits of their understanding.
We have burnt athletes at the,
at the stake of performance
that we didn't understand all the ramifications of got the job done.
We lived on the clock.
Let me use an analogy for you.
I learned this from you.
This is like,
this is one of the from me.
Yes.
This is one of the swear to God guiding forces in my life.
Don't hang tough.
Okay?
Fear factor.
This guy had eat like a foot long horse cock in like an hour.
Okay,
that never happened.
But go ahead.
Uh,
there's,
we'll hang tough.
He had eats something.
So you,
that guy's eating right and he's making jokes and you're like,
hey bro,
watch the clock.
It was like in the best of fear factor to watch the clock.
Watch the clock.
You're trying to help them.
You're coaching and he's making jokes.
He's flirting with the girls,
he's eating and he swallows the last bite at the last second and you're like,
sorry bro,
you timed out.
And the guy freaks out.
Yeah,
I remember that dude.
I was trying to tell that guy.
I know what you're doing,
but you can't do it.
Don't do it.
Don't fucking waste your energy talking and having fun.
I'm like,
you got a lot.
I,
I've been there before.
I've seen a lot of people eat dick.
It takes some time.
Takes some serious fucking time.
And you think you take the first couple of bites like I'm fine.
Did you?
You got five minutes.
Eat that whole Dick.
It's not that easy in Kabul and Dick's got that.
We got to watch the clock.
You gotta manage the details.
You also have to have chewing endurance and that sounds so crazy,
but there's shit like livers and kidneys.
Kidneys is a perfect one.
Somebody tells you,
Hey,
I'm to make a bet with you.
Listen,
you want to make some money?
Tell him mother fucker he can't eat a kidney like a cow kidney.
Tell him that he can't eat it in an hour cause he's not gonna fucking eat it.
Just to make sure he can't have any water.
You can't wash it down with shit.
You just have to eat it.
It's not happening.
Okay.
It's not going to happen.
It shouldn't happen.
You know how I know I'm an expert on that.
I know,
I know.
I've seen,
I've seen a lot of people,
I've seen pas do it for 100 bucks.
I've seen contestants do what?
You can't eat it.
It's too hard.
It's just shooting the shit out of something.
It's like you're running up hill sprints with your jaw.
That's what it's like.
That's right.
And so you're wrestling Karalyn with your draw.
Can't train for that.
The kidney is insurmountable.
You have to control what you can control,
right?
So it's when you learned that from her,
I've got to control the clock,
Bro.
So let's say that I'm,
I'm teaching kids to do like a,
what's like a,
not a wizard,
but like a suplex.
There you go.
And,
uh,
if I don't teach kids to get stiff and brace against that the same way we teach
our young throwers,
we teach them to arch as hard as they can without arching the can is meet
cranking on those,
those joints over and over.
This pattern was set up from him in high school and Middle School billings reps
accelerated under big loads or 300 pound guys accelerated in the ring.
So could we have extended his career long enough and more importantly,
I want these fighters to finish their careers and not be disabled.
I want them to finish the careers and have some aches and pains and hey,
they tore their ACL but they shouldn't be disabled.
The same thing with our firefighters.
Same thing with our kids in the army,
you know,
were in your forties you should still be able to train.
She's still able to pick your kids.
And we're seeing is that that guy has rung the bell on his back seriously
because maybe he played pro ball and,
and,
and some had some unfavorable things.
How do we maximize this positions?
Brian,
what the fuck are you putting on TV?
Buffalo.
A penis.
Buffalo Penis?
Yeah.
Oh,
everyone's so happy.
Okay.
Stop Bro.
Goddamn Ustream.
Okay.
This isn't your house.
We can't just be showing that shit.
I don't even think it's legal.
Buffalo.
Buffalo Penis makes me giggle every time.
Um,
I forgot what I was going to say.
Fuck,
we'll,
we just talking about where were we at?
We're,
we're just,
how do we,
how do we extend the careers of our best assets and when it's finished,
how do we do it?
So how,
how so I love,
I mean,
you should be able to wrestle your whole life,
right?
Oh,
Jesus Christ.
So you crazy.
And you do the Jujitsu when old guys don't do Jiu Jitsu too,
but you gotta,
you just gotta flow role.
Those old dudes,
they do Jujitsu,
but it's a different thing,
you know,
were all guys and know what's up.
Yeah.
You can just pick out this hungry.
My friend Yoshi is a 63 years old and he's a black belt and there's John Jacques
Machado and he's very technical,
but he's a little guy.
He's a Japanese man.
He's 63 years old and he's only probably 145 pounds at the most.
He's not a big guy,
and he'll find the guys to roll with it.
He's smart now,
but he's,
you know,
he's going to do a genius because he moved really well.
He knows Jujitsu very well.
I mean,
he's a John Jacques Machado.
Doesn't give out and fake black belts.
If that guy's giving you a black belt,
you're legit.
So if Yoshi is a black belt,
he's a real black belt.
It just,
his,
his movements are,
you know,
he's just smart.
He doesn't want to taxes body 63 years old.
So when he,
he rolls,
look,
if,
if shit came,
the shit hit the fan and he had to choke you to sleep,
he could chuck you to sleep.
But he doesn't want to have to do that every day at 63 years old.
You know what I mean?
No,
no.
It's a slow rolls.
Lost some of the tissue tolerance I think we are in,
we're in an IEP.
That was a retired,
he's retired.
I mean,
what does,
what does retirement age,
but so 35 he usually,
it's typically what
once retirement age for patrol for like people work at the post office.
Is it 65 or is it 55 65 what did he use?
He used to be younger and they extended it.
What's it like 59 at one point or when I'm making that up it's gonna be so bad.
No.
Yeah,
I think,
I think it's longer now because people's health.
Yeah.
Well I'm talking about just people in general who retired from jobs and this guy
is going in there doing Jujitsu.
You know,
master young men takes care,
but also look at,
look at some of the,
the management and training your opponents.
It's very important that isn't that important.
Yeah.
Those young kids shouldn't be,
you know,
you could ask a lot more autonomy at all.
There's the young kids,
I 100% trust
it would,
it would.
It's all about is not wrong with Yahoo's not rolling with anybody who doesn't
know what they're doing.
A dive on shit that doesn't really work.
They just land on your ankle or something,
just cranking on limbs for no reason.
You're fucking list.
We call it around the technical term for it called hanging on the meet.
We see those kids all the time and they do same thing.
They also
get really excited about tapping you too,
which is like settle the fuck down.
Like you're trying to tap someone too hard.
You know you're,
you're not in a position where you're really effectively utilizing that
technique.
You just squeezing the shit out of it in a bad spot.
Like you actually wasting effort because all that guy has to do survive that and
then you're done.
You know you're done.
You're not going to,
all he has to do is get through this one.
Squeeze does count 20 don't tap and then dominate you.
Yeah.
And flow,
flow rolling.
Like you said,
it was an art in and of itself.
Right.
So,
and it's an art and trust as well as his flow.
Kickboxing,
you know,
you know that is much harder,
which is harder to control,
strike impact and you,
you see the time skilled.
So I spend a lot of time in Thailand and,
and they don't spark at all when they had work.
It's all five work.
It's all clench works.
So like 50% of of their trainings clinch work.
When you were saying earlier,
I mean uh,
not a lot of people realize very underrated growlers.
Oh shoot.
It's like,
I mean most of mine grappling comes from white tie and then I'll go in and,
and Russell Division One wrestlers and and and that all applies like
shite.
Fuck around that guy.
Y'All some Cli.
All those guys boot cow shat guy has incredible trips because of boot cow.
They outlawed clinching and k one because Robin and because the Allister over
you until they wouldn't allow the double hand cause he would grab you.
He's so strong.
He's a fucking gigantic power lifter dude.
He gets a hold of that double hand.
Is it on their knees are coming with this sparring.
You watched the Thai spar?
No neath pads,
no nothing.
And they,
they know what's up,
tapping each other man,
he's super relaxed.
And when you do find a training partner like that,
it's a beautiful thing.
Like you will progress,
you'll meet you like two o'clock,
you wanted me to two o'clock and you'd,
you'd both know that neither one is going to do anything stupid.
It's quality numbers flower to be able to get in some quality now.
And then you develop the quantity,
then you develop those,
those instincts where you're,
you don't even know you're doing the movement till it's already over.
See,
and this is what's brilliant really.
What with Kelly system for example,
let's take the squat.
Like if you understand some of the underlying principles of the squad,
what he's talking about,
porn,
Cordova,
crew creating torque rings,
stability,
right?
You see that same rules applied and Jujitsu or in fighting,
So you know,
when you throw a cross,
you,
you know,
turn your foot into the ground.
All that,
all that is is,
is a mechanism is stability,
right?
You're just creating stability through the hip so you can transfer that force up
through the ground,
through your body,
out through your hand.
So if you're practicing that in strength and conditioning,
right?
Say we're practicing a split jerk,
our squad or whatever it is,
we're able to,
to,
to practice those mechanics.
So then when you go into your sport fighting,
whatever it is,
it's transferable.
All of a sudden you see it.
Even windmills.
Exactly.
But it's all the same.
Yeah.
Same ideas.
You're right,
right now
throw in the fact that these guys have cultures around massage and sleep and
these weird recover when jerked off.
Right?
Chan Pero Pero they don't fuck around dude.
Penis stadium.
So check this out.
No,
let,
let's,
let's go.
Let's go here for a second.
One of the problems that we have with athletes who are,
uh,
in a very sympathetic state,
right?
You're fighting just a training.
It's a very high sympathetic state.
So your sympathetic nervous system is up and going.
You're in it's fight or flight kind of pounding.
We measure this with heart rate variability in our athletes.
We can put a heart rate monitor on you in the morning when you breathe in,
your heart rate accelerates.
When breathe out.
Decelerates kids who are not recovering,
their heart rate stays the same.
Boom,
boom,
boom.
They're driving,
you lay down at night,
you're just,
you can't turn off.
I know good coaches who've worked with like NBA players.
The only way that NBA player can come down after the game or term training and
practices as smokeable and rollout on the foam roller.
And that really is about tricking the body into accessing the pair said,
look,
nervous system.
It's not an accident.
I think some of there's cultures around physical cultures have some of these
things built in about bringing you out of that sympathetic state and bring into
that parasympathetic state,
which is about adaptation recovery.
So that's that state where you can,
so I mean,
how weird is that that that uh,
you know,
getting a hand job and a Thai place after your fight is really also about,
oh,
it's relaxing.
So guess why you start to recover.
You sleep better.
Right?
So there's a whole,
one of the things we are,
you know,
how are we systematizing that?
How do we give people their access to their diaphragm?
So one of the things that I'm interested right now is,
so my uh,
my Ninja,
like special forces guys come back from the Gan.
They've been in long deployments.
They call them Ninjas.
One more time.
You were officially my Goldberg.
I don't,
I don't want to say who they are.
Scary guys saying okay that just sounds like something that testosterone comes
back in.
The testosterone is really low.
Their testosterone's like one 70,
which is that of like a nine year old man.
Man,
that's high.
So He's all drain.
So if you,
if,
if these guys are caught in this sympathetic outflow state right there,
just that,
you know the h the dirty secret of pro sports is ambien.
Like that is,
it's such a dirty secret of guys getting on the,
on the bus back up from after plan.
They take an Ambien,
all the soldiers surviving starts sleeping and taking the Ambien to take to EMV
and they wake up and take another ambien.
Like this is how they're trying to sleep again.
So we start measuring all of this stuff,
yet we're in bad position.
So if I'm overextended,
which is more,
most of us are living,
we're,
most of us are living in this overextended position,
not this Uber flexed.
Your lower back is overextended.
Your upper back is slightly flexed,
and this is like when you're sitting up in the car,
when you're standing with your feet,
turned out,
your pelvis is dumped forward a little bit.
When you are in a bad position of your spine,
your body doesn't work very well.
The whole thing,
just like your bad position,
the foot you can't kick as well,
it can't move as well.
Well,
the same thing happens with the musculature of your trunk so that if you're in
an overextended position,
your pelvic floor doesn't turn on,
which means you can't create as much intra abdominal pressure.
This is why you see over Extended Women Exercising and they pee when they
jumped.
Right,
dude,
but do double unders and Pete comes out when they're that bad because it is
women.
It's not pretty.
It looks like for you,
the John overextended peer.com a party in my mouth.
Don't,
don't go to Olympic lifting prolapse,
bell.com I don't do that.
I've been there.
So when,
but also the same thing happens or in vain.
So when you're over extended through your pelvis,
your pelvic floor doesn't turn on.
When you're overextending your rib cage,
your diaphragm doesn't work very well.
And so you start doing this breathing in their neck.
And so I don't have good access to your,
your diaphragm control cause it's just in a bad position.
So you start making vo two compromises,
right?
You're not putting out the same via to your breathing is inefficient.
That diaphragm has attachments onto your so as like the whole system starts to
get away.
Why?
Because you're in a bad position.
So in that sense it's,
yeah,
that's really interesting.
Look at where the guys take the shot or they hear no,
they're really straight up and down.
Right?
Breathing out,
managing that breathing because it's that clinches.
So aerobic and then in that sense it's,
it's actually very important.
It never overextend yourself then.
It's never,
it's,
it's important,
especially during training to extend yourself to the brink.
Never overextend yourself.
Never get yourself in a position where using shitty form,
well,
that's going to happen automatically.
It happens because it's called training and your coach is like,
that was shitty.
Right.
It happens because you shouldn't because you're improving.
That's right.
The practice of that learning with your left hand,
you made a ton of errors.
You,
you,
you integrate your making mate.
Major feedback.
How do we be more feedback?
I want you to make errors if you do it more than once.
It's practice.
Right.
That's that's the difference.
What's our brother laundry?
Yeah,
sure.
What have you got the,
you got to those more of those a ciliary sciences,
those are Goddamn also brought you a bottle.
Champagne too.
That's what we drink.
I had a cider in England and in Ireland.
Those are the only times I've ever had cider.
They love it over there,
man.
They say,
you want to sign it or I'm like,
I thought we were drinking and then they give you a cider and you're like,
oh shit.
This is delicious because you're still thinking you're still thinking of Zima.
That was the,
gave you the bank side or entice them?
I fucking drank Zima till the day they pulled it out of bars.
I didn't give a fuck.
I remember I was at,
I was at the Improv and a John Hanson.
Remember John Hanson from talks to,
he was like,
I can't believe you're drink and Zima.
I was like,
God dammit.
John Hanson.
I enjoy a fucking Zima.
I want them to drink this email.
I'm going to do it with pride
bottle was like a little bottle of Miami vice like it had like it was art deco
had a black,
he had a black label.
I know,
I'm telling you that's what gave it a bad.
Remember the ad.
I'll have a Zeeman to police I believe.
I didn't give a fuck about that.
A that shit tastes delicious.
Marks Heights hardens.
Don't confuse me.
Okay.
That's why I get mad when people get shitty with advertisers.
Listen man,
that is one of the easiest con games of all time.
That's three card Monte for blind people.
All right,
and you're getting mad.
You get mad at advertisers.
How dare you.
They are weeding out cheap.
If you can't figure out that if you buy that car,
that girl will not fuck you.
If you can't figure that out,
then you deserve to lose every penny.
Your stupid ass figured out how to squirrel away.
That's a Macklemore pup and text.
It's true commercial.
That's what I'm talking about,
dog.
You don't get excited about that car thinking this girl is coming.
You know,
you brought,
you brought up something that we're starting to see is that culturally there's
this shift going on where some of the big corporations,
some of the best thinkers are not saying,
they're saying like,
Hey,
stop blaming the corporation.
It's like it's not Mcdonald's fault.
It's your fucking fault.
We don't chain kids certainly is that and is also a,
you know,
look,
there's nothing wrong with having corporations as long as the,
even if the corporations are bullshitting people and in that way with
advertising rather,
not align,
but,
but it's also,
it's,
it's us that are not accepting responsibility for our own diet and getting
together and figuring out the same amount of time you spend pursuing your
career.
You spend that amount of time pursuing your diet.
Truth a hundred percent consider your diet.
You consider what you're taking into your body.
Make sure you're getting the proper vitamins.
Are you?
How much?
How many vitamins are you getting in a day?
How much fido nutrients,
how much water are you drinking?
How much sleep are you getting?
And if you think about all the other shit in your life,
like your career and your fucking score and starcraft,
do you think of it?
All that shit,
but you don't think about your body,
your fucking upset.
But people are
taking responsibility for Nucor.
So now than ever more so now you see it everywhere.
Documentaries,
books,
whatever.
But what hasn't been done?
This is what you know.
What I've really taken from Kelly is he's putting movement on the table.
Moving position as a skill.
Reading is a skill.
Sleeping as a skill or just skills.
You teach your kids out to sleep,
right?
The new,
you've got them all out.
You got to sleep,
drug them,
they fucking scream and shit.
You got to drug them.
Well,
the fact is that's what we do.
Stunt dark.
You were saying earlier Joe,
like,
oh,
I messed around with a crossbow and I feel better.
Like everybody should know that,
but everybody knows now like,
oh,
I should eat real food as opposed to industrialized food.
Right.
And that's just like common knowledge.
It's becoming common knowledge,
you know what I mean?
But it's not common knowledge that you should roll around a Lacrosse ball or
that I should understand that I should sit or stand or be in these better
positions.
They don't get that.
They're like,
oh,
I'm in pain.
They wait until something's wrong.
And then they go to the doctor and they're like,
oh,
you know,
do this and do Musashi's my whole right arm.
Whoa.
Oh Shit.
Come on.
That's Musashi versus a tiger.
When I was a kid,
man,
the book of five rings is one of the most important things I ever read.
I remember I was reading it and I was like,
in my mind I was like,
this guy fought with fucking swords.
Listened to him.
Yes.
He learned some shit.
That's what I mean.
Like he was,
it was,
it was he jerking off when he was like,
Hey,
you organize yourself being a combat stance all the time.
So if you took massage or your fighter and you take it,
you take them aside,
she's word at it.
Is Your combat stance,
your everyday stance,
is that how you're standing when you eggs?
Yes or no?
For me,
no.
I cook eggs naked with a hard on.
That's a good position.
None.
No,
that's a good position.
I'm not saying back,
I cook,
I cook
eggs with one hand in my ear like I'm picking my ears.
Terrible combat stance.
Musashi was a bad motherfucker.
I mean he,
he wrote a lot of amazing things and one of the most amazing things he wrote was
the,
the need for balance,
the need for art,
the need for philosophy,
the need for calligraphy.
Did he carve the or?
Yeah.
On the way.
Kipchoge Kipchoge's s exactly.
But what you're saying is it sort of balances that it makes sense because what
you're saying is that you need to balance your body out.
And what he saying is your body is just a part of your whole,
you need to balance the whole thing out,
your mind,
your personality,
everything,
all of it needs balance in order to perform at your optimum level.
Exactly.
It's so movement is the missing piece,
right?
So like nutrition,
sleep.
People get it.
People understand they need to be hydrated,
they understand they need to exercise,
but do they understand what those good positions are?
Do they understand what like if I have knee pain,
it's not,
it's not just out of nowhere.
It's because I gave myself on knee pain through bad mechanics and bad movement.
Right?
Unless I was,
I have pathology,
catastrophe mythology or guitar hero.
He was probably a better swordsmen in Japan then.
Right?
He fought with a long sword.
You understood how the long format,
I use this analogy for our are really tall athletes.
I'm like,
quit fighting north.
Quit moving like a little short guy.
You're not right.
You're six foot five.
So be like a long sword,
but he wasn't integrated.
He didn't bring mindfulness to all the things.
Why are you practicing this training?
Why are you lifting weights?
Why are you fighting the whole point of this ultimately don't Barf self
actualization.
That's what it's about.
Yeah.
No,
it's,
it's not a Barf word.
That's,
it's a word that's been co opted by.
People were barf worthy.
Yeah,
and that's the problem.
It's like people say spiritual.
I'm not religious,
but I'm spiritual.
Well,
you know what that means to me
that's what it means.
Run because you're about to get an a stupid fucking conversation about Horace
goals.
Someone's going to tell you about,
you know,
experiences they've had.
My grandmother was there with me.
I felt her shut your mouth.
You don't even know what you're saying.
Anytime there's a girl named crystal and I'm,
I'm usually it's crystals.
Those crystals liber 10 that they give you power.
Yep.
Dammit.
You got,
I mean totally.
This is this whole conversation and literally the people you're bringing on is
saying,
what is the optimize self?
How much more capacity do I have?
The the metaphor for saying the training.
What if I didn't ever fight or expresses,
but I should still be a skilled human when I pick up my kids or when I'm cooking
or when I'm lifting my groceries to the same thing.
Sure.
The F in Physio,
we have this test.
It's called the timed up and go.
You'll like this.
The tug test,
right?
You get out of it.
Why are you pointing at him?
No,
come on.
He's a cause.
He keeps falling off the horse.
Cock on the TV.
Do it again.
If you,
if you,
uh,
you know,
you get out of a chair,
you walk three meters,
you around,
you sit back in the chair.
That's the test.
If you can do it fast,
you're not less likely to fall and kill yourself.
They can measure that.
There is a famous hammer thrower name Litvinov who had a squat workout.
He did on Mondays.
He would front squat 200 kilos for seven reps and then run 400 meters.
Those things are scaled.
What we have to do.
It's the same thing getting out of a chair,
walking front,
squatting,
running,
same.
Our thinking has to be integrated enough.
I'm glad this is Buckminster fuller talking about integrated systems,
right?
Mutually coming systems.
It has to scale for my kids what you need to eat as the same thing your kids
need to eat,
how you take care of your bodies while your kids take care of the body.
It has to scale up and down.
I have to be integrated in all the systems and if I don't,
no wonder we see so much wasted effort with all the kind of bs problems we're
dealing.
Let's take that off the table.
We have a chance to get it right this time.
I'm sorry.
I mean this.
This is the message of hope,
but literally you should be empowered because there are people talking about it
and putting the information out for free and in,
if you don't understand how it's not impacting the quality of your life,
you're,
you're leaving it on the table.
No,
I think you're making a lot of sense and I think this is the first time where
this kind of information has been so freely distributable.
You know,
like using the Internet,
using Twitter,
using youtube videos.
I know you put out a shitload of videos,
right?
How many videos did you put out?
Like 560 yeah.
And you just slammed them out there and people eventually took notice.
I mean that's just how it goes when you have quality ideas.
And that's the beautiful thing about this world is that all Kelly start needs is
one dude to find that video and say,
hey man,
check this shit out.
And that dude sends it to another dude and he goes,
man,
I've been having a problem just like this and hey send that shit to Lenny.
And then boom,
boom,
boom.
Next thing you know it just takes off like it's on fire.
Yeah.
Bas on not too long ago,
boss route emails,
don't you call him back so fucking find you.
He will live or kick the shit out of you.
Is left side still good?
There's a,
he's a guy.
You could talk to cause bosses had to be serious neurologic and guess what,
he,
he started using my stuff on his neck and he starts sleeping better.
I bet he did his um,
his right arm is,
uh,
he was talking about on the podcast,
it's like his wrist all the way up.
He lost like amazing amounts of muscle tissue,
massive astrophe atrophy,
pinching of the nerves and he's had two neck surgeries so far.
And you know what man,
for a dude like that,
like former UFC heavyweight champion,
if,
if the guy's an accountant and his arm turns into a noodle,
you know,
it freaks him out.
But a guy like boss Rutan heavy weight guy that could do a one arm pull up.
Yeah,
that's serious.
He was an animal that video the video of him.
He's an animal animal animal.
I fucked up co Shaka for the,
for the title when he fucked up,
TK just teed off on him.
Bas Rutten was like one of the best strikers in that day.
He was one of the first guys to really incorporate like a high level athletic
striking style.
He was a Prequel,
Cro,
cro,
cop,
but even more mean he knows he's ever been slapped by the fire.
And it was also the thing about boss,
he could take it.
Boss took it for with Kevin Randleman.
He won the title off his back time.
He's just got it
right.
People say,
you know,
hey,
he doesn't deserve that.
Like Jean Bell called me up.
Right.
That's dumb.
Preggers please stop post shit I ever seen in my life.
But gene,
the bells,
a grappler and he's a judo champion and he let you do it at the same time was
random and trying to advance position?
No.
Was He drawing strikes?
Was He showing strikes?
No,
I mean,
I mean blocks.
Reuben was fucking him up for his back elbows and he was trying to advance
position to him.
He's trying to sweep,
he's trying to get up.
Randleman was just using his superior wrestling and keep them on the ground.
He took a lot of shots.
A lot of people didn't.
Here's the,
here's the rub though.
He did not want to be there and that's why a lot of people think that random and
won that fight is cause random and put him where he wanted to every single
fucking time.
He just was unable to do anything other than keep them there and boss was
throwing these strikes off the bottom.
The question is how effective were those strikes and what dictated the fight
more?
Honestly,
I say random ones.
Wrestling dictate the fight more because he took him down whenever he wanted to
and he held him down whenever he wanted to.
Boss fucked him up from the bottom,
but he only fucked him up from the bottom cause random one guy.
And this is where I think that judges need to start taking into consideration
damage inflicted.
Yeah.
Like you look at it,
you need to,
you need to be able to say,
you know what I mean?
Like you look at a guy,
what,
what was the fight like?
Kampman Sanchez for example,
where it was it close by.
But you look at both fighters and Canon look pretty clean.
You know,
then you'd just been in a war.
But giggle look like Elton men like to look like not the day go got a bad guy's
a fucking beast obviously.
But I mean the point is you got to be able to tag,
you gotta be able to take into account the amount of damage done on the bottom.
Like you see it sometimes guy on the bottom is going,
you say it all the time,
God's going for submissions.
Who was attacking who the guy is attacking.
You know what I mean?
Yeah.
Sense Bas Rutten clearly one.
Exactly.
No doubt about it.
And I,
I agree with that.
I think it has to be sort of an accumulative thing.
And I also think we should take into account more what happens at the end of the
fight and be
this is going to sound no,
this is how Moitai is,
judge.
Fuck No.
Listen and,
and Thailand and they don't even judge the first two rounds.
And,
and people who have been in Thailand or San Moitai know that they play music
during the fight.
Yeah.
So as a fight progresses,
that tempo increases.
Yes.
Right.
And the idea is that as a Timbo increases that they're going to increase the
tempo,
the fight,
they're going to fight harder.
They're gonna.
Yeah.
And that's the tradition.
They don't even just throughout bedding.
Yeah.
So exactly right.
But they don't even start judging the fighting.
And granted the judging is pretty corrupt and,
and,
and not balanced.
But the point is they don't even start judging until third round.
So these guys have fought for six minutes already and the fight doesn't even
start according to the judges until the third round,
right?
Yeah.
The third,
fourth,
and then the fifth.
So every subsequent round is just higher than that.
And that's why it's can't just ever be about who's the best physical specimen,
whose training is the most complete,
you know,
this is why rocky beat,
I,
right.
It's will.
And that's why competition keeps us in,
especially if it keeps us in.
Because what you're really seeing is
let's get to the heart of the human spirit.
More importantly,
how do we take all the other bs off the table?
Because if you're out because your knee or back,
you can't explain it.
Yeah.
Well,
we all know that one guy that's like super talented in the gym but can't put it
together.
When he fights,
there's certain guy bleed.
I he.
Yeah.
Right.
I totally agree.
There's certain guys that in the gym,
they're the most frightening people on earth and then something happens to them
when they compete and they fall apart.
It's really strange.
I know some guys,
we all know.
Yeah,
you all know that guy that just,
everybody knows.
Some guys
and we know some guys the other way as,
wow,
we're guys that aren't physically talented,
but they're just fucking ferocious and they find a way to win this one mother
fuckers fighting above his head where everybody's fighting 10 20% below their
capacity.
It's like his expectations have been lowered so much by his own physicality that
he goes in there as an,
I don't give a fuck.
I'm going to fucking fight with what I've got.
Whereas everybody else is like,
don't fuck up.
Don't make a mistake.
Like it's almost like he benefits from being the underdog.
Yeah.
There's less pressure on the underdog.
Every,
all the fighters say for sure like I'd prefer to be on dog cause it's legit.
All the pressures on the guy that's expected to win.
You're like dude,
all I got to show up,
I'm not going to disappoint anybody if I lose because everybody smoked.
Sound a little
subject that's been covered.
The psychological managed poorly you see covered much more than New York.
Your ideas which are physical movement,
physical movement hasn't been discovered or really like a tune on that same
level.
Well and I think it has been discovered.
I shouldn't say discovered.
I mean more like integrated people don't understand that how they squat will
have a direct effect on how they punch.
Like people haven't connected those dots like well Kelly is trying to say
earlier about making the connection between strength and conditioning and like
fighting for example is that if I understand what the athlete needs to do when
he's squatting then I don't need to be a fighting coach to know that he's going
to lose power when he punches.
So I can watch you squat and I can tell already based on higher squatting,
say your knee is caving in and your ankle is collapsing and you have a shitty
squat.
Right?
Right.
Well I can tell right away that that that's your motor part and that's your
default movement,
right?
Yeah.
So if you take that movement and you transplant that into a fighter,
a guy that's throwing a punch,
well I can deduce that that's going to be the same motor pattern.
So it's easier to fix that movement pattern when you're squatting.
Like,
okay,
let's get you to understand the correct mechanics of the body while you're
moving in a controlled environment.
And then hopefully over time that becomes ingrained this then,
yeah,
and when you throw a punch,
then it's like they started make the connection.
They're like,
oh shit.
You know,
like I tore my ACL because I was squatting was my foot down and my knee was
caving in.
That was my,
that was my brain.
Like when I needed to be in that position,
my brain was like,
this is your position.
Does that make sense?
It has to scale.
So if,
if we look at the,
the science of chronic pain,
for example,
the pain pathway,
and this is important for athletes who are chronic pain,
especially
people who are engaged in high contact sports,
these bad positions get mapped with the,
the movement pathway.
So your brain starts to think even if the pain stimulus isn't there,
your brain starts to think,
oh,
you're moving this way,
that's been painful for the last six months or the last year.
I know it's going to cause pain.
So if I give you a brand new motor pathway in your brain,
boom,
I get this clean motor pathway,
I'm able to get athletes out of painful positions.
That's like,
I mean that's check Yonda thinking right there.
I wanted to ask you about two things.
We've got to get to gluten before we end this thing.
And so,
and the other one is head trauma.
Is there you,
you were talking about how the body has the ability to heal itself,
but it seems like it doesn't with head trauma is not the case.
Head traumas is Super Gnarly,
right?
I,
I think,
uh,
you know what MMA has done for,
you know,
decreasing head trauma for boxing.
You know what I mean?
Like it's,
I don't people understand like it's so much better.
I don't know if that's true.
Is that really a true look?
I support MMA obviously more than anybody,
but I think that,
uh,
that's actually been disproven.
I think that,
um,
there's concerns.
Impact is impact in fact,
isn't that,
it doesn't really,
there's more possibilities and MMA to defend yourself in boxing,
but impact is impact.
We have to mitigate.
Yeah,
absolutely.
So if we look at lucky leaky brain and the inflammatory response and the quality
of your tissues,
how do I optimize this things?
How can I change that?
Can I,
can I limit the damage?
You know?
Um,
one of our friends who,
uh,
his name's John Welbourne,
played in NFL for a bunch of years,
part of that big brain study,
and they basically went in and looked at his brain afterwords.
They're like,
you played left tackle.
We can play in the NFL for 10 years.
We can tell by the head trauma that you have.
They took tests and he uh,
you know,
he was like 99th percentile and analytics in like he was maybe 10th percentile
and emotional Iq.
Right?
Because of the rain tropic strong dude.
Which shitty emotional fears.
Well we look at,
so some of the NFL or guys,
these head trauma guys,
boxers as well,
boxers.
So anterior pituitary gets damaged too in there.
It's not just the brain that gets rattled.
So suddenly I throw off the neuroendocrin access.
You're not making HGH,
not making Gonadotrophin,
you're not making testosterone so you're not making sense.
Your tissue start to fall apart.
You start to lose your sense of self identity.
So,
so how can you optimize that?
Well,
you know,
are there,
are there mouth guards that change some of the forest?
We're working with University of Texas right now on looking at concussions with
Cro.
Copped the,
the Chin to the dome doesn't give a fuck what kind of mouthpiece and blow it
was.
Like,
how many of you know,
it's also,
you know,
we're seeing there's a higher impact of blows when it comes to cakes and that
has to be taken a consideration as well.
There's some things that are happening right now with wheel kicks would
[inaudible] with Edson Barboza Barboza started off here,
knocked out Terry yet Adam and then it was a Uriah hall and then everybody was
like,
what the fuck is going on?
And then [inaudible] and everybody's like the fuck.
And
then God Damn Junior dos Santos,
the first time he's ever thrown into fighting knocks out mark fucking hunt.
So Bruce Lee was right.
Oh well that,
that technique is a motherfucker.
Boy.
When your pants are up in my kitchen,
I know I stay away from you.
The amount of force you could put on the end of that heel bone is insane.
Insane.
It's a half beat.
Strike me that the time it takes for the person turn actually gives a flinch
response where someone got guys on.
Yup.
Oh Shit.
He doesn't know what it is.
He doesn't think it's a kid.
What a perfect time as you're a young guy.
Training on a ne practice.
This shit,
because people aren't used to this is the thing is they're,
they're trained to and and,
and MMA like it's been,
it's been now guys are training pretty conventional.
You know,
that's why you get a guy like pedis or you get a guy like tor and desantos those
guys,
I guarantee
background be towards rose.
So few kicks and all of sudden he's got two head kick knockouts in a row.
It's fucking crazy.
You have this thing,
it's disaster.
Hard kick to head.
What are you going to do about it?
So you're,
you're throwing him.
I'm going to be an MMA fighter.
Like I'm gonna try and make a left as a professional fighter.
You know,
I'm going to pay a price.
He got knocked out a whole bunch to a really supports your ideas,
man.
I gotta tell you that.
Cause vittores it fucking tremendous athlete.
He always had,
he moves so well in every form and look how quickly he's picking up this.
We'll kick shit.
That's right.
One of the,
one of our definitions of best athlete is who's the kid who can pick up the new
skill the fastest,
right?
How,
how fast can you learn a new skill?
And you,
you probably,
you know,
you see those kids that,
could just be like,
they show up,
they're like at the hobby sport kid.
All of a sudden they're back flipping off the trampoline and then they're better
at you.
You're smart,
you know that,
you know,
so how do you create that athleticism.
But also I think one of the things that you were talking about with the gluten
is how do you measure lifestyle?
How do you measure nutrition,
you know,
and,
and came for by a t cell count.
Can you optimize those things?
Kent,
can you optimize the healing response from being knocked out?
Can I,
you know,
we have all this amazing a supplementary medicine,
right?
A lot of guys,
you know,
go on the gear because they need to go on the gear should go on the gear in
their forties when they're starting to break down between them and their
physician.
You in favor of that?
About testosterone replacement therapy amongst combat athletes.
What I think remind you combat athletes.
Yeah,
calm down please.
This is different.
It's also damage to the pituitary gland.
I think it depends.
Like if you take,
for example,
you have a guy that's experienced,
say he has been fighting for 30 years and he gets,
and now he has the same testosterone levels is a guy that's 20 years old that
hasn't been fighting more than two years then I think that that's unfair.
Right.
You know what I'm saying?
But if you it,
so it's just like so subjective,
depending on this weird how,
how often are they being tested and what are their levels during training and
the,
are they leveling off to a normal level when they're fighting and what are they
doing during the week,
the normal
testing and throughout the training camp.
And then,
yeah,
I don't think so,
but some guys,
but that's how Alistair Overeem got busted and house drove him randomly.
Surprise.
This is,
this is what
my friends who,
uh,
who know about these things say,
look,
they've never seen gear.
Make a crappy athlete,
a great athlete.
It allows good athletes to train harder and to recover faster and get more work
done.
And whoever does the most work and remains the freshest wins.
That makes sense.
So if I'm also looking at you afterwards and you're not making tea in your life
sucks.
Are you kidding me?
Like we have ways to manage it.
It's never a really cute romantic yeah,
region of the idea.
But the reality is it improves you drastically improves your ability to perform
work and improves your ability and it also improves your explosiveness.
It improves your speed and improves your power and improves a lot of things.
It's not hand eye coordination,
being able to track out the balls and do that,
but if you already have those things,
it will make you better than a t.
T does change the way you can.
I see what you're saying because of the,
the,
the power and the,
just the change in nervous system.
The,
especially the,
the hyper hypo levels
levels that some of these super app,
let's,
let's go to back to the pride days.
Okay.
I'm not alleging that anybody did steroids,
but God damn it looks like a lot of people did steroids.
He that Sarah and the people that were over there told me people were doing
steroids.
Do I know people did steroids?
I do not know that people did steroids,
but let's just assume.
Let's not name any nationality.
Let's not.
Let's not say.
Well,
let's think about some certain fighters that just looked insane.
Jack to the Gills.
They didn't even look fucking human.
They would come out with veins on the tip of their nose and Jane Markers and
fucking raw when they won and he would be watching that you like that is barely
referees or an MMA fan.
You have not seen pride.
You are doing yourself a disservice.
I would suggest start with the Vandelay Silva collection because that is the
quintessential pride fight.
And if you don't know who fade or is shame,
shame,
how dare you fuck up today.
Before Christianity,
the fade or pre religion Christianity.
Man,
I think you just got up.
I visited fame February and I,
I didn't see any of that.
Oh really?
Yeah,
Dude.
So when did he take that on?
I don't know man.
It was,
it was definitely posts.
We worked on a book with him and it was definitely post book though that that
guy must have been going through dude carrying the weight of a machine and,
and just strolling,
killing monsters.
Wait,
put our Lawsky away.
Flying the protocol and for Gte,
after Fujita fucking rang his bell
by sound or Kristen flexing on his neck.
It's a book over there.
Fringe,
ology.
I mean like,
that's fringe.
That guy's out loud.
Well,
you know what that guy was?
That guy was bulletproof in the brain dude.
And when his brain was just ferocious,
he calls him the terminator.
That's how they all refer to him in an interesting like study and not wasting
energy too,
isn't it?
You never saw him was face 10 stop or saw crazy.
We'll allies.
It was always like really relaxed and it's probably the guy trained,
you know,
eight hours out of every day that,
you know what I mean?
Those guys train hard.
We awesome
as far yes.
Put it back into the realm of this room of human performance.
Let's say that you're actually eating right,
let's say have a great coach and you're moving right and you're actually eating
right and sleeping right and managing this things,
then then you're,
you're augmentation choices matter even more.
But we see people making covering up bad lifestyle,
bad nutrition.
And that's the problem.
That's my biggest problem with that stuff.
Can you make a guy who doesn't have punching power and can you give him punching
power?
Yeah.
Or is that a certain innate thing?
I mean I think we've all,
we've,
yeah,
we've all met those guys that just have that like they touch you,
you're out power.
It's weird to give a guy that can give a guy fun to write,
but I don't know man.
And I've talked about this a lot with like fighter friends and coaches and
whatever,
cause you always know that guy weird.
There's a guy,
Liam Harrison,
he's Moitai fire.
Probably not too many people know who he is,
but they,
everybody should write,
you know,
one more time.
I mean he's got that just weird.
I touch you,
you're out power.
Right?
And,
and I think a lot of it is one,
it mechanics play a lot.
I have a lot to do with it.
Like if you don't understand how to be in good positions and understand the
transfer and energy through the ground up through your body,
all that stuff.
But you cannot argue with that.
There's just some of those weird guys out there,
Joe,
you use with those guys where you just like,
you get hit by him,
you're like,
that shouldn't have not.
I've heard as much as it did just now.
See the fires,
Matisse,
boxer,
Lucas,
Matisse,
Nah,
he's this new guy.
He's just Kale when people left and right.
It's,
it's amazing to watch.
What do you think about that?
Speed on guys think it's a bone thing for one.
Just density,
right?
They just saw her weight and size of fists.
Like,
so some people have a very large fist like George Foreman,
George Foreman.
Suppose they're like ham.
So like canned hams.
And there's also the,
like Tommy Hearns have this,
uh,
the shoulder with thing I think shoulder with has to do with leverage and it has
to do with the amount of,
the amount of extra travel that's going on before your punch lands.
If you have like very narrow shoulders,
you're not getting as much rotation into your punch.
But if you've got some Tommy Hearns type shit going on,
by the end of that punch,
there's a lot of torque.
When,
what did the Russians do?
They developed all of these skills.
We have a,
we have a coach in our gym who's,
who's Russian,
who was plucked out of the Ukraine to be in a Russian swimming program when she
was five.
Well then basically they just trained her GPP.
GPP,
GPP.
GPP is,
they identified her general physical peronists skills.
They taught skills to these kids.
And then guess what?
They decided,
oh look at that kid has huge shoulders.
He's going to be good.
This,
this kid is upright,
has long torso,
short legs.
He's going Olympic lift.
This girl's going to swim.
They start making decisions and it's serendipitous for some of these guys who
kind of find their calling and find their skillset and they have hams for hands
or maybe,
right.
Yeah,
and I think it's like you said,
this is like you can still make the best athlete in the world better through
good mechanics.
Take the slack out of you.
That's awesome.
It is.
It's interesting because it really always becomes a disproportionate battle
because if a guy has perfect genetics and he's intelligent and he's disciplined,
he's hardworking,
he's going to beat the guy who's just hardworking and has shit time,
shit,
slow jeans,
you know,
fucking,
we all know dude's you.
Just,
especially when it comes to striking,
striking is and when it becomes apparent,
there's something about Jujitsu that allows you to be technical and if you're
positioning knowledge is two or three moves ahead of the other guy and you role
long enough,
it seems like eventually you catch them for the most part,
unless the guy's like really defensively minded.
But dudes or help us when it comes to striking,
when a guy has that fast twitch muscle fiber and the good conditioning and the
skill set,
you're fucked.
And that's what people don't realize.
Striking.
This is different.
Like what Jones Jr is a perfect example of that.
What do you mean when you,
my George Junior was in PR in his prime.
He has such incredible athleticism that it doesn't matter how Christy or boxing
is.
You're,
you're fucked.
So how can you quantify everything and he got older and his reaction one or to
talk to you about that because I want him to talk to you about steroids cause
there's,
there's two things with Roy Jones Jr.
Okay.
And I'm like,
I say this in all due respect.
I'm a huge Roy Jones Jr fan,
but he changed the genre Weise fight.
It was in my opinion of the turning point cause we went up to fight John Ruiz
and he fought John Ruiz at heavyweight and he was big.
He was like 200 pounds and then he dropped back down to fight Tarver at light
heavyweight and he looked like shit physically.
He looked drained,
his musculature was deflated,
he had a hard time making that way.
He'd dehydrated the shit out of himself,
making one 75
his,
all of his mechanics change.
So we know this from our power lifters who I have a friend Jesse Burdick,
who is he?
He did elite total at 219 pounds and then six months later went up to three 18
and power lifted there.
And when we,
there's a weight component and you have this natural weight and all of a sudden
you drop a whole bunch of weight,
your mechanics and leverage changes.
Your proprioception changes.
Like the game is different.
I have a friend who's Mark Bell,
great powerlifter,
his brother Chris Bell did the documentary bigger,
faster,
stronger.
So mark was a heavyweight to say
Justin,
as you're moving now because of it,
we own it all.
So Mark's now at like two 42 and he had to figure out how to bench again.
He's like,
I don't,
nothing was stable.
I don't know where I am.
And so we don't even think about that with our fighters.
Hey,
you're doing carrying all that,
how moving it around and once.
So part of the gay friend,
part of the game is,
how about this,
how it part of the game is like as water management,
right?
And and if we look at just being to hydrate or just salt being down,
just total salts,
you can still have that reaction time coupled with being dehydrated.
A couple of challenges in the nervous system,
you're not sleeping very well because you're stuck in weight and then all your
positions change,
all your mechanics and your kicks don't feel the same to change.
Your weight class is legit.
It's so hard.
It really is.
It's really,
it's a,
it's an also,
it's all,
what's the elephant in the room is the gear.
Um,
you know,
I think you have to,
if you're in your thirties and you gain 30 fucking pounds,
you're on deer.
Okay,
let's just be realistic.
Let's be realistic.
Six months.
What do you think the percentage is a pro?
So let's just be safe and say that Lance Armstrong,
fuck that debate sideways.
Like now it seems like almost everybody,
like you'd think like 80% if you're going to put a percentage behind the global
will,
like all sports,
I think.
Yeah,
I think that might enter name.
I'd be like 80%.
I think MMA is actually lower than I think most professional sports.
My opinion,
there's guys like Roy Nelson,
guys like John Fitch going against like,
Hey,
you know what?
Fuck.
And they'd taken a stance and now they're knocking them and it's an honor and a
valor thing.
Totally opposed to bank.
It's combat.
It's like,
no,
just go back to basketball.
No,
no,
not at all.
But like in basketball you're not hitting it another person in the face on
purpose.
Agree more.
And I think that it's also,
there's a reality of the sport itself,
the impact that you take over and over and over again,
and just in training where you're going to get the kind of traumatic injuries
that almost don't heal naturally.
It's a natural occurrence.
Don't heal on the parameters are still have to train.
I still got to get work done.
Yeah,
you're absolutely right.
That's 100%
this is the condition of the fighter is that they feel like they,
the,
you know,
in MMA specifically,
you have so many variables that you have to cover.
So you're constantly,
you're,
you're constantly pushing to train every single variable all the time and is
very difficult like,
right.
So you're always overtrained like most MMA fighters nowadays overtrained and
then they look for something like,
hey,
how can I recover so that I can fit all this fucking wrestling and boxing and
Moy Tai and skills into like a day session,
dude,
I've trained for Fides,
I've overtrained it's fucking impossible and not do it.
So how,
how do we look around then and say,
okay,
I'm,
I'm a fighter.
This is my main thing.
How do we look around and say,
someone has invented this wheel already.
What are the best practices elsewhere
with fives?
When I say it's impossible to not do it.
What I mean is it's impossible not do it if you're not approaching the whole
situation.
Knowledge.
I believe with a heart monitor and someone who knows what the fuck is going on.
And I think that's what really what's,
but Joe,
what's crazy about this?
And this is what we're cause.
So just a little bit background.
So like Robb Wolf,
Paleo solution,
a nutrition genius,
right,
right.
I was lucky not to gray guy.
Yeah.
So I was lucky enough to be under his wing strength and conditioning and they
can officially not.
Yeah,
exactly.
But like what's,
what's great about like Kelly brings to the table is everybody knows like all
the fighters know like,
hey,
I need to eat correctly,
I need to sleep,
I need to train,
I need you all this stuff.
But none of them.
And I guarantee you this,
cause I didn't know it.
None of them understand like the,
the movement blueprint.
Like,
Hey,
what's the master blueprint?
What are the key fundamental principles that I need to know to optimize moving
function?
So for example,
if I'm going to optimize my nutrition,
I know if I'm taking a Paleo stance,
I know that I need to,
I need to get rid of gluten,
right?
I need to maybe in some situations though where my carbs or,
or,
um,
ditch dairy or,
oh damn,
hold on,
hold on.
And,
and maybe you can still buffer it,
right?
So,
but people know this,
but my point is,
is like,
fighters know this,
but not a lot of people understand,
hey,
what's the movement blueprint like,
okay,
I'm in pain.
I know I'll be in less pain if I don't eat gluten,
but why am I smelling paint?
Oh,
we keep saying that without even explaining it.
So let's get into that
because we've got to wrap this pitch off in about five minutes.
What's wrong with gluten?
Gluten causes inflammation on disproportionately for different people.
Some people have a small reaction to it,
some have a big reaction to it,
that inflammatory constantly inflammed state.
That means that you did not adapt as well.
You're not recover as well.
It's like always running a low grade infection.
I had a Chiropractic,
just tell me that.
So she was talking to me about an inflammation test recommending the Mckenzie
Protocol.
It's a bunch of different kinds of stretches.
Test,
test,
retest,
kill the gluten.
Do you feel better?
Yes or no?
Did you times go better?
I feel better except when I'm eating.
That's the problem.
So damn good.
Linguine with clams is one of my fucking weaknesses,
man.
I am a mostly Italian.
You can eat shit and to want to sit down with a bullet.
It ticks.
Hey Mom.
Hey Mom,
this is in gluten free.
You're dead.
Somebody trouble the fuck.
Tate was trying to tell me what you could have a little spaghetti squash.
I'm like,
how dare you complain?
Spaghetti,
squash,
spaghetti squash to Lasagna.
You shouldn't be knowing my friend Tate.
If you're eating right,
you should probably be able to have lasagna at mom's house and not many us.
Right,
which he used to do is like have a day,
right?
Well,
not even a day.
Like,
listen,
if you're in,
if you're at a wedding,
you're at your daughter's wedding,
you should probably eat the fucking case
and don't be an ass.
If I'm making bread,
it's homemade bread and the bread,
there'll be an asshole that's unique event.
Unless you have 365 daughters,
Joe,
here's the deal.
Like everybody's on a spectrum,
right?
Like you might be on that Spec,
that one in like Kelly was just saying where you can eat it and not feel sweet.
Fuck all right.
But you can be on the other end where you are,
you have celiac disease and like you eat too much of it.
You'll like
with alcoholics as well.
How about this?
We measure,
we've,
we ask all our athletes to get a good blood panel that we have worked with a
company in our gym that's kind of started out of our gym and we like,
don't just take your cluster,
we fractionate your cholesterol.
We look at the inflammatory markers because you're suddenly,
you're like,
oh,
I'm gluten free
and dairy,
but I'm eating bacon every day and we saw people's cholesterol like triple,
quadruple.
It turns out like you're not actually,
I'm not set up to run that much saturated fat and eating nuts.
Newport bitch.
Cause let me tell you something and I'm fucking float through big and like I'm
a,
I'm a surfer on the bacon fat highway.
It's okay.
Does he mind goes on this fight.
It's cool.
Go right ahead.
It's beautiful.
As I get my cholesterol checked and it's terrific and I'm floating on a river,
a bacon to handle it and the,
and the
hanging 10 on baking.
But the key is how do you know,
will you measure it?
So you,
you did what you said exactly what we need to be doing.
How do we know what we know?
We,
it's observable,
neutral,
really bullshitting.
If I have begun once every four weeks,
it's a lot.
I try to eat pretty clean.
I um,
I try to eat only things that grow in the ground.
I try to eat grass fed meat as much as humanly possible.
So that fighter has a hunter forum.
What's that?
There's a fight or hesitant because own cowboy,
it's around.
He has his own hunter for him.
He has a guy,
Tim Sylvia again is a big hunter.
He eats all her Brock Lesnar that guy.
Yeah.
If you,
you,
you a hunter.
Do you meet?
Oh yeah.
You eat you like,
did you go hunting?
Do you ever eat venison?
Yes.
I have crazy theories about food when it comes to,
especially things that are fast.
I think things that are really difficult to keep that away from you.
I think they're better for you.
That's why they're so slippery.
I think we figured out how to beat the whole fish thing with hooks but tried
catching a fucking fish without a hook and meanwhile Fisher nutritious is shit,
you know?
I mean they're like really fucking good for you.
What if for say,
you know what you eat,
you're what you eat,
eats,
what does what you're eating well,
would it be like super healthy deer eat the,
eat a lot of grass and like leafy vegetables and delicious nutrients are in
their protein.
You know,
you eat them and they're,
they taste so much better.
Concentrated vegetables right there.
Africans eat.
What's your question with gluten,
they fly hamburgers.
You ever seen that there?
That is the most fucked up thing.
They eat mosquitoes and flies.
They'll take out like a bucket and they,
they whip this bucket through a big cloud of flies and bugs until they get it at
the bottom of the bucket and they scrape it into patties and make burgers out of
it.
But it's protein mean you're fucked.
You don't mean that you're in Africa.
You've got to do what you gotta do.
It's right.
And the human being is designed for survival.
My question,
because this is going to end really soon and thank you very much for doing this.
It's been beautiful.
We've got to do it again for sure.
Um,
the,
uh,
the issue with gluten is it just our bodies are not designed for it is,
it has to do with genetically modifying the actual weed itself,
which did happen in like the early 1950s or sixties,
I believe.
I forget which one,
but look it up.
I don't have time to Google the,
um,
the,
the people that were making wheat in this country,
they,
they sort of,
uh,
engineered it to be a stronger hardy or wheat and that's when people started
having issues as far as like digesting it.
Um,
some people didn't,
some people still don't.
But for a lot of people it's a big issue.
My kid is super sensitive.
She won't eat the birthday cake.
She's some frosting.
She gets a freak.
I don't,
you can only talk to you.
You've got an alias rule.
I just had a five year old birthday party at my house.
Kids were eating cake.
Like it was fucking going out of style.
How dare you,
how dare you lie to the children?
Hey,
you're a terrible father.
Now I'm a beautiful father.
If your daughter got some real cake and you weren't around,
she would go crazy.
The problem is she'd go crazy.
I'm just teasing.
I'm sorry.
I don't even remember.
It just looks you're on.
We were talking about gluten.
I mean
here's the deal.
We,
you should never take our word for it.
You should test and retest yourself.
Don't take anyone's word for it.
Go ahead and dump a bunch of medium chain triglyceride oil into your coffee with
some butter.
And tell me if it doesn't taste better.
Yes or no.
Do you feel better to have more energy in the day?
Yes or no?
This is the only thing that matters to us.
Like you are your best experiment and you have the right to experiment yourself
as a whole life.
No just sorry,
but like you were saying with the Lacrosse Ball,
like you do that right?
And then this is like the brilliance behind Kelly system.
It's like you do it,
the test retest is immediate.
Like,
oh my shoulder feels better daily.
You are really literally immediately asked earlier,
what do you do about knee pain?
And,
and,
and it's just like one,
you correct your mechanics and understand what is the movement that's causing
the knee pain and then to like what can I do on a tissue level that's going to
improve the pain immediately upstream downstream.
You should
going on with the recall.
What is the Lacrosse ball doing?
Like when the crop Lacrosse Ball,
like what's like the technical explanation has this material that absorbs your
pain,
what's happening in a soul.
You are stiff.
You're,
you're improving the function and the congestion and the,
and the uh,
the hydration of the tissues.
One,
two is that you're undoing this stuck pattern of Fascia so you change that until
it moves again.
Three is that you probably get your ribs moving forward is that you change your
thoracic mobility,
you change that orientation of thoracic spine and the whole system up regulates
your in a better shape.
Last question.
What is it about gluten,
cause I don't think we totally cover this.
What is it about it that makes your body inflamed?
What's going on when you take it takes the,
the s the small intestine,
the small intestine.
That's it.
How's it?
Is it because it's a foreign thing that it's not normal to the human diets,
right?
What it is,
it's like having a root canal festering your mouth.
That's your small intestine.
Yup.
My Jam,
but it's,
it comes in the form of Spaghetti.
What do you understand and don't own is just a protein,
right?
You're small and Tony Nods.
Donuts or gluten.
Oh,
fried and sugar.
Capsuling with dogs.
I'm out of Harris waffles.
Oh my God.
Waffles.
The Belgian waffle.
Even sometimes chicken because fried chicken is made with bread.
It's in denial.
Joe Rogan,
you will never go gluten free because you just can't let go get heroin.
You're right.
I'll never glow like no.
You will still get cigarettes.
You to go low.
Gluten free.
One cigarette a day.
How many,
how many servings of gluten would you recommend in a week for a man like me have
obviously robust character and strategy.
Was that the right justification begins?
How much heroin can I have?
Is it that that drug is,
but it's not right,
but like,
look,
if you're looking at possibly thinks is a drug,
he thinks gluten the drug,
it has an opiate effect in your body,
right?
So tiny,
like a similar effect.
Maybe not the same to the same degree,
but like,
look,
what you have to understand is are you trying to optimize your life,
your function,
whatever,
whether it be movement,
sleep,
whatever it is,
is listen,
is your money.
You're making your money from your body and you're making your money from your
body.
If you do,
why are you pointing?
When you playing those corners like it really,
you're right.
You're like,
uh,
this,
you're making your money from your body,
but most of the people you're talking to aren't.
But even for them,
optimization.
And also there's a reward for that discipline.
When you eat on Sunday,
if you have a cheat day on Sunday,
if you eat six days of good food a week and then a one day you'd go off or a raw
human being,
you're a human being or you might be the rock rock's Twitter,
he's got the greatest cheat days of all day,
but you can buffer a bunch of stuff.
I mean,
you can hear,
you know you should and you should live a life like mark Sisson has a really
reasonable ideas about this.
He puts a little sugar in his coffee.
He's like,
you know what?
My life is better when I put sugar in my coffee.
Sumi a pussy for the record.
That's a compliment it.
That's such a nice thing to say about.
Good thing.
We already established and that's how we're going to end this.
We're going to go full circle.
Thank you sir.
I appreciate it.
That was awesome.
Kelly,
you're a bad motherfucker and if people want to get Kelly's book,
it's called becoming a supple leopard.
You have a copy of it,
Brian,
or she'll put it up in front of the camera.
Look at that becoming a supple leopard.
Dr. Kelly start,
you are a bad mother fucker sir.
And I appreciate you coming here and much we study some books that I really
think it's going to help and I'm so glad that you were the guy that invented the
Lacrosse ball.
Cause that thing I'm telling you has helped me more over the last couple of
months.
Demons.
It's,
it's so hard.
If I get a person massage you that hard,
you know,
and you can get a massage or,
but they don't tell time exactly where your bullshit is.
Jackie
dove a
dove,
a dozer,
doza whatever changing named son.
It's not as catchy as the Mexican version.
And Glen Glen Cordova and gentlemen,
shout out to Arish.
Um,
uh,
thank you everybody for tuning into the podcast.
Thank you.
On it,
go to o n n I t used the code name Brogan.
Save 10% off any and all supplements and please follow Kelly on Twitter.
It is mobility w o,
O,
d,
which is workout of the day.
So Mobility,
m,
O,
d or w,
o,
d,
excuse me,
mobility WOD on Twitter.
And Glenn,
what is your,
uh,
you got a Twitter man,
that's gangster as fuck.
That's gangster as fuck.
Do you have a Twitter?
No,
I do not.
I have a Twitter,
but yeah,
we'll be back on Monday with bobcat.
Goldthwait ladies and gentlemen,
bobcat returns a podcast,
a big kiss.
And we're going to work out something next week for Kevin Smith.
Uh,
we're going to go to his place and do his podcast.
Holla.
Brian,
you wanna come.
All right.
He wants you to come to.
All right,
we'll,
uh,
we'll see you guys Monday.
A Jihad.
Praise,
Odin.
Big Kiss.